Recording.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan and.net,
what's my name?
Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight entering the code name
Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I said it.
Charlie Murphy's here,
bitches buckle up,
but hello
it fill a git until the music kicks in.
That was voiceless to Charlie Murphy and freeze love land rich.
Charlie doesn't fuck around.
He brings a whole fucking posy to your house,
Dude.
That's true.
I like it.
I bought the whole camp.
Freeze.
Love is my friend from the old days of the comedy store.
I've known freeze for fuck.
I like a decade now,
if not longer,
if not longer.
Probably about 15 years.
Been a long time man.
You've been having a lot of unions is weak.
I have.
It's been a good what's going on?
I've been in New York,
I've been in New York for like eight,
nine years now.
So this is my first time back in New York and around back in Ela,
you know?
Yeah.
We go way out in Ontario,
you know,
out there.
But we're in Hollywood.
A lot of people like,
Gee,
I thought you were dead.
And so you guys have been doing a lot of touring,
right?
Oh yeah.
Man.
All over the country.
Outside of the country.
In fact,
we're getting ready to go back to Europe again in October.
Oh yeah.
And then I'm doing a show down at Guantanamo Bay.
That's going to be big.
That's probably when we'll film my next one hour special.
One time.
Obey,
Huh?
Yeah.
Charlie Murphy lab to tell Holy Shit.
So it'd be 100% soldiers.
How did we send soldiers?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Go hard to real big.
Well,
they let you talk about whatever you want as far as we know.
Yeah,
man.
I mean,
I was like [inaudible] you know when I come down there I'm,
I'm not pulling no punches.
They was like,
well,
no problem.
Well,
I,
there was a great story that Louis C K wrote on his blog about going to,
going overseas to entertain the troops and how,
you know,
enthusiastic the troops are and how good it felt and everything.
Boat.
Yeah.
I said he kept getting in trouble.
The Shit,
he just couldn't help himself.
Higher-Ups.
Yeah.
Cause they didn't,
they wanted him to be fairly clean and they would just go dirty because he knew
that's what they wanted to hear and then fucking trust.
Right.
Crazy.
And after the show,
if the general shows up and he had a problem,
I'm like,
well I'm not in the army so fuck you.
Keep it moving.
Some scary people you deal with.
Even though we're both veterans,
man,
this ray man,
you had your chance to get over.
I'm not doing pushups for you.
Then instead I'm gonna come and do my show and whoever don't lag.
You guys were both with military.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
I was in the navy.
He was in the army does,
this is a different breed man.
People have been in the military.
You,
your eyes are more open.
People have been in the military are like,
Whoa,
this is for real.
Oh Shit,
this shit's for keeps everybody out there running around playing doctor,
you know,
want to know how the world really works.
Even like when they show him the news and they show like a live footage of a
firefight on the news.
If you was never in the military,
he was never around a real five,
five frank.
That's not the same thing as being there.
You know,
like what you see on the news.
It has an effect on you definitely.
But being there when it's going on,
it has a different effect.
100% of people get desensitized seeing shit.
Exactly.
You ain't gonna be set aside and he's standing there.
Yeah.
And bullets are flying by and realize this could be it right now.
This could be at any moment.
That's true.
Yeah.
Just a different breed bound people have been involved in the military are
completely different breed that.
So it's a hard way to live,
man.
And for a lot of people,
you know,
this is not a lot of fucking options in this country.
You know a lot of do to jump in.
I'm gonna tell you something man,
if you ain't,
if you ain't got nothing going on,
it's not a bad choice.
Point blank.
If you ain't really doing nothing.
If you,
if you're sitting back going,
well that's a hard life.
I don't want to do that and you're not doing anything.
You need to do that.
It's better than doing nothing.
Yeah,
it's a that's why I went Joe,
cause I would have ended up doing nothing.
I was just sitting at the house getting in trouble,
you know?
Yeah.
Nothing was going to work it out.
So it was like yo go to the military and I got it together.
So if you,
if you're not doing nothing then that's where you need to go.
Well No,
men definitely need some form of discipline.
We definitely,
we need some form of discipline.
We need something to shock us out of our complacency and kept us moving and we
need something.
That's true.
Camp should be mandatory for every man.
Once you turn 18 whether you go to the middle of champion,
that I think your boot camp experience,
you know you should go somewhere and you know,
cause you're going to learn,
take something home with that.
No,
you're good.
You get in a situation where people that do not love you have complete control
over your life.
That's a good,
that's a good understanding of life.
Right?
You know,
these are people,
they don't,
they don't care about your feelings,
they don't care.
It doesn't matter.
And you're going to do what they say dude.
And if you don't,
the repercussions,
there are a lot like life.
You know you right and you're going to be in a bad situation.
So on the alarm you
come out strong,
you know,
like you don't trip out of other stuff like other people.
It's just fascinating that we like to pretend that our society is any more
evolved than the Romans or than the Greeks.
You know?
And then you really feel like,
you know what the military really is.
You know,
it's just design.
Our hired army,
the people we pay to go fuck people up and just keep it,
keep it smooth over here,
keep it smoothed over here.
Everything over there.
It's tear it up,
tear it up.
Crazy.
That's a,
that's not always be the situation on the planet.
You got as long as you got people in different countries and all that stuff
going to have compensation
for resources and you got to have own.
I know,
but we don't,
we don't have any idea what it must feel like to be invaded.
That's gotta be some trippy Shit.
Could you imagine if you were living in Afghanistan for say,
you know Afghanistan is a fairly rural place.
It's a very strange country.
There's only one real city cobbles the real city.
Everything else has all these,
these territories run by warlords.
It's very strange and fall of a sudden tanks show up giant metal tanks and
fucking jets flying overhead and you're like,
what the fuck you just out there where your goats and your Betches trying to
keep everything down.
Yeah.
There would be an all of a sudden ism American troops are tanks and guns even
more scary to imagine it happening here,
period.
Oh yeah.
My House of course
identify with the fear would happen at my house.
But if I looked at her mom black,
nothing tanks coming up the block and all that,
that that would be,
well,
we like to pretend that we're the peak of civilization.
Right.
But we're doing that to somebody else.
The peak,
you know,
they're easily could be,
uh,
an advanced race above,
you know,
or a advanced country rather a above this one.
There could be some new military power that all of a sudden starts taking over
and we could be in the same situation that,
you know,
other countries are as opposed to us.
Oh yeah.
They could have definitely something.
Anything,
I mean,
things switch over time.
It might not be something instantaneous,
but an a,
an a few months or a few years time.
It could get all fucked up.
It could.
I'm going to tell you like my service,
I was in Berlin and uh,
this was like in 1985,
86 this was all before the wall had come down.
And Berlin,
we were literally stationed in the heart of Berlin and Berlin is,
is like Manhattan of Europe.
So we would have tanks rolling down city streets,
right.
Past city buses.
And it was,
it felt weird.
It felt weird.
But how did the people respond to them or desensitize?
That's been that way since the,
you know,
since they put the wall up and 61 or 62 whenever it was.
So they were used to it.
But even for me,
I never got used to that.
I was always weird.
Wow,
that's good.
That's one of the things about going at one time when they had that wall there
too,
you know,
when I,
when I was in the navy,
went to get more.
So when I go back to perform that,
and it was my first time there,
but they have that wall there with the soldiers on the wall and they paint.
It tells you if you approach that gate or if you tried to go through it,
did they shoot to kill
you do both sides.
Both sides of it.
If you tried to come to us,
they shoot him and kill him.
You tried to go get insecure.
They shooting the kid.
Isn't it fucked up that,
that's cool that we allow that.
Like there's,
there's some uh,
area 51 spot where if he crossed the line,
there's a certain line where you get too close to area 51 they're just allowed
to shoot you.
It like,
yeah.
It's like you cross this line.
We've seen nothing like what the fuck,
what kind of ridiculous rule is that?
That's,
that's so ridiculous that the people that are in charge of the government would
allow something like that.
You can just shoot someone who's driving and you don't have to explain shit,
you know,
security.
You might,
they think about it.
What's,
what's behind,
what's all in there and area 51 you might be like,
if you knew what it was,
he would be like,
listen,
they got to shoot anyone that comes in here.
And I've always wondered,
I always wondered whether or not it's really alien shit or whether it's just
secret government projects.
You know,
everybody claims Alien Shit,
but if you don't know what the fuck they're capable of and you think it's one
thing,
but it really is far more advanced,
you'd probably think it was alien.
And then the,
the rumors get spread.
And,
and if you're some scientists that's thinks he's a bad motherfucker,
but meanwhile do some Russians at figured out some shit that nobody else has and
we've got their information and it's in a hangar somewhere in the desert,
you know,
you,
you stumble upon that,
you would probably think that's alien.
You'd probably think,
where's this coming from?
Oh my God,
you made it fully,
fully realized human being.
You'd think he's an alien because most people in that,
you know what I'm saying?
We don't use,
we don't use our home brain bro.
We don't know.
We the only the only species on the planet.
No,
we only use 10% of our brains.
The brain capacity.
We only use 10% of ash.
Why?
How come elephants using,
I heard even send them it bears and their elephants.
They can't drive cars,
but we use 10% of ours and we do all this technical stuff.
I think that's an urban myth that I'm saying 10% I've seen it.
I was pretty debunked.
You started the buck.
It's looking it up right now he's looking at which is check cause I want to
know,
I've heard that before.
Now 10% of our brain we don't use,
we don't use our tag capacity.
Don't
why not?
You know what I'm saying?
Or is it could be in control.
Yeah.
It's a black anything it's been,
yeah,
it's a method.
Yeah.
We,
we,
we talked about this in the podcast once before because I had heard someone else
say it too.
Um,
it's,
I misquote misquote of Albert Einstein or the misinterpretation of the work of
Pierre for Florence
Murphy Dismiss quoted and Stan and Pierre who Florin Florin.
It's one of those things everybody says you waited from Roosevelt Junior,
senior high school.
So that's the ending.
Newton south class of 85.
No.
I think a lot of people think that people,
people say this all,
we use 100% of my brain.
I don't think they understand it that way.
I think that,
I think we know what areas of the mind are stimulated during certain activities.
We can monitor the mine,
but there's a lot of the,
what is the consciousness?
Where's the consciousness store?
Where's the sagging portability?
Right.
Person is special that they just tapped into something that we all have,
but we don't all use it.
You know what I'm saying?
I think most psychics are full of shit.
Most of them.
Not all of them.
No.
I'll leave room cause that's what I'm saying.
When you see somebody like Michael Jordan,
the way he took away,
took basketball,
he was the psychic.
No,
I'm saying he tapped into something.
He tapped into something that nobody else tapped into as far as playing the
games,
his turn.
Yet he took him to the highest level.
Yeah.
He took it to the highest level.
That means nobody else can do that.
But him or just that nobody else tapped in to what you know.
Well,
there was also frankly,
as you know,
you know this freaks like you know,
like just like John Holmes had a big giant deck that's abnormal abnormal deck
and your world in my world.
Yeah.
Who's steals a better example?
He's a black guy with a giant Dick.
Okay,
that's a,
that's unusual
Oregon.
Who's to say that there is aren't brain's capable of being hyper powered like
that?
Some guys got to fucking 20 inch Dick Brain,
you know,
and that's what it is.
Three twenties dig brain that he's fully fully realized to us.
He was seem like an alien.
Like this guy's so smart.
Right.
They hadn't won a news.
He was doing all this different mathematical solutions at one time and he was,
he was talking like 15 people and he was telling them when it were,
the day they were born through asking them math questions,
the day that their children were born,
he was telling,
answering questions about their life with Matt and he had,
yeah,
he had a whole room full of people.
There's one guy in the world that does that,
but then they go,
then I have to go,
what is he tapping into that makes him or allows him to do that?
It's,
and it's all manipulation of mathematics.
Wow.
His grasp on understanding mathematics as he could.
He could do like a thousand joints,
the mathematical joints at one time and you go on one cause once to three times
six Jesus,
while you're doing that and he's doing 1520 of them at the same time.
You ever see those dudes played chess where they played 10 games at a time and
they'll walk,
you know,
it was a table
by one of those guys that fell hard.
Really horrible.
I feel like an idiot.
That's dude names.
When I was in the navy,
took amazing,
took the entire mess deck like 45 guys chess boards in front of us started at
the first guy that he walks to,
the last one.
Then when he walked baked then maybe three laps,
which means he'd beat everybody in that room in three or four moves.
You know,
he,
he took everybody quick man,
but this guy couldn't tie his shoes though.
He had to wear loafers.
He never,
he never could master tiny shoes or blacks
really call it an idiot.
He was a weapons officer,
man.
He was real smart with stuff like that when we came to common sense things,
glue them away.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
Life balances itself out in one way or another.
Somehow bounces.
You don't get to be super intelligent and be cool.
Right.
This guy that's got these real thick,
I mean super duper thick coke bottle glasses and what he does is he looks at it,
they took a picture of the New York skyline of three 60 picture of the New York
skyline and um,
they showed him the pictures and he's got the pitchers all up close to his,
to his eyes,
to these thick glasses.
And then he walked into,
he walks into a room and he paints with a pencil.
He draws the whole skyline.
Exactly to a tee from members.
That's a kid that can look out the window.
Are We?
Yeah.
We've talked about this kid before.
He can look out a window of a plane and see a city and then draw that exact
image.
Right.
It's incredible.
It's,
I'm saying they're using the same muscle.
We use the brain.
Yeah.
I think when you see something like that,
you got to say,
okay,
well clearly there's levels of potential that haven't been tapped.
If we're evolving and we think we are right,
we think at one point in time where some lower primate and we evolve to become
human,
we're,
we're not going to stay this.
We're going to get something else,
and when you see these servants,
you see these people with crazy abilities.
What that represents to me is potential.
This is,
this is a potential performance of the human body,
but what?
It's just not working in all of us yet,
but if this guy can do it,
yeah,
yeah.
He shits himself and yeah.
Yeah.
He can't fucking watch TV without screaming and running into the walls,
but he can still take a picture with his mind and draw.
Right.
You can't do that.
If you could do that too and all the other stuff you do.
Wow.
Right?
Yes.
When we've evolved cause I mean if I had to take my choice,
I think I'd rather just not be able to draw on not shit my pants on myself.
I would say that too.
I would go with that too.
Yeah.
I don't want to be
extreme example that's crying all the time.
Some extreme example,
it can't get my shit together.
Listen to him play the violin,
just keep doing this cop.
He shut himself,
only wants just keep doing these problems,
becoming the best at something and anything and trying to become the best you
are.
You risk becoming a fucking mad person.
You're a crazy person to get out there and to really get out there to hit the
highest highs,
you almost have to just be fucking nuts.
You almost have to just let it all go.
You almost have to get you just willing to go to places that the other people
won't go quicker than they're willing to go harder with more discipline further,
further,
further.
And as you're doing that,
man,
that's a separate from the pack of you fed separate from humans.
Right.
He gets so wrapped up and trying to accomplish something and you become crazy.
You know,
I've seen it happen.
I've seen it,
I've seen it.
I've seen people go crazy.
We've seen,
yeah,
he was,
he shot lasers at me the other day because the folks who don't know Robert
William and provider is a comedy store legend.
He's a dude who used to hang around in the comedy store and he was always like
wearing like plastic bags and stuff.
He's kind of homeless and uh,
he would have all these one liners about weed.
He knew all this information,
but we,
his whole act was about weed.
I mean like if she want to grow 35%,
then you need to have five clones,
but you have to catch them at the right month.
And
he bought a new suit recently.
Did I say things are on the up and ups with him?
All right,
I'm glad he's alive.
Pharmaceuticals baby.
He was always very friendly.
I've never shaken his hand,
but we've always been very cordial and friendly to each other cause he don't,
he won't touch,
people do want to touch people.
And I tried to give him knuckles once.
I,
I prefer not to do that.
I prefer not to.
And a so he doesn't like being touched.
The poor guy and you know,
you can only speculate as to what the fuck that's all about.
Someone doesn't like being touched.
I mean who doesn't like a good hug every now and then?
Someone who got,
again,
this was a guy,
we want it to be a comedian so desperately.
I mean he
just put himself in the comedy world.
I don't,
I don't know if he was ever funny,
but he,
he made me laugh a few times.
Yeah,
there,
there were silly,
he had some silly one liners that were funny and they,
he was molested by a fellow comic and that's what heavy did.
Maybe we didn't give up the knuckles
fat,
nasty.
Looking at fake big Dick Black Porn.
Oh yeah,
like where it's like,
yeah,
this is a really,
they have the artificial dicks and they don't pull them out.
They keep them in their pants and they just like pull out this fake Dick again.
That's my day.
It doesn't even look real at all,
man.
No,
they just do it.
This guy makes films,
he makes videos,
but it's a fake deck and you could buy it if you want to have a fake big black
dick.
It's so ridiculous.
I mean,
he doesn't do his special effects budget is very minimal because this dude
doesn't even take his pants off.
He's just got this fake Dick Poking out of it.
The guy's name,
who was the Main Exhibit Hall Jab Time Boogie
Woogie Song called I brush their hair.
Oh my God.
We met this guy and he came to the show and he said he wanted to do 10 minutes,
which I always let you know any communities that local would come and do some
times she's never said that on the Internet.
What I said,
I said,
I let them come better get busy because if you don't know what's going to
happen,
so you,
that's beautiful.
You let anybody do 10 minutes anywhere.
Everywhere I've been,
dude's come up to me said,
Yo man,
I'm struggling.
I'm trying to get it cracking,
you know?
Wow.
And then you let them go.
Up and do timeouts.
Charlie Murphy,
you're on time.
You're a fucking beautiful person sometimes to the audience is shit grin because
you know sometimes it's terrible.
Wow.
This dude came up.
He had to,
he had to fake that going around his knee.
Okay.
Hopes to kill boss Dick wrapped around his knee.
Was that part of his act?
He was came up,
he was prominently displaying is fake Dick and I was and I was sitting in the
back going,
wow,
you know,
we can say,
well we want,
but that showed me this,
that is so big that it's show business
he's on.
He's on a stage is a light on him and people looking at him,
he had everyone's attention.
Every
kid what you want to say about it,
that Showbiz and therefore that could be you that could be used.
So consider yourself,
consider yourself fortunate that you don't have to pull them fake big.
Stand in front of a crowd and get paid.
Harrison was songs about your chest.
Hair.
Yeah.
You,
that's a hell of a way to make a living.
Being in the military is hard.
Shit.
That's hard.
A hard time getting the guys offstage where they don't want to just do 10
minutes.
They want to keep going.
That dude wanted to stay and he thought he was killing them.
Everyone was looking at him like,
Yo,
what is this about?
Okay.
Jokes.
So
I think even a lighter,
he was bugging man,
you took the craziest path into comedy ever,
man.
And I always admire you for doing that.
When we met Charlie and I did this thing,
the maximum comedy tour,
Oh,
it's Charli me and John or have fraud and we had a great fucking time.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
we got to become friends.
But I,
I was always impressed that you took,
you were an actor essentially when you went on Chappelle show,
you would just a guy who was really good at telling stories and a really good
actor and the brother of a,
the most famous standup comedian possibly of all time.
Right.
And you just jumped white into a headline in man.
Oh yeah.
That takes some crazy balls.
I think about like when I first started doing standup,
if someone said,
okay,
now you're going to do 45 minutes,
I want to just shit all over myself.
You just went right in.
You never had a moment where you were like Charlie Murphy,
the Middle Act who toured the country and tried to do little gigs.
Like you just went right into the fucking flame,
which is really hard to do and said,
Eh,
I'm going to have a freeze lovers.
Yeah.
And told me don't throw the whole bag.
Do you?
And,
and,
and that's,
Yo,
we blend it too though is because of the age I was when I started doing standup,
I was like,
you don't get time for it.
You are already,
you know,
jump,
you don't have time to really opening for people and showing you don't have time
for it.
You got to show up with something to say to you.
You have something to say.
Okay,
we have something to say.
Let's go,
go iron it out and make it happen,
you know?
Yeah.
Not leaving it alone.
So you
the philosophy by the time you ever got on stage.
When I first got on stage I was 21 I was an idiot.
I didn't know shit.
I had no business telling anybody anything about anything.
So I'll just talk about pussy.
I'll just tell sex jokes.
I mean it was like my whole act
because I wasn't the first time I got on stage home
and did a show and got paid for it.
I probably got paid wait when winning is not deserved.
But once I tasted the money
old was
just telling me I can't go back up on that stage again.
You Dot.
Yeah man.
I was like I'll do whatever I have to do to stay up there.
I was telling people no one is,
look man,
you don't understand.
I'm going to beat you up for real.
You know what?
I'm really going to bust the makes them on your face.
You better let it go cause I'm not giving this job up,
you know?
And I stayed with it,
man.
How old were you when you first got on stage?
42 wow.
Wow.
What was that like?
Man is what a giant like shift in your life.
Like all of the sudden Jim was here touring all over the fucking country,
personally perform on the first two years.
I didn't believe that,
uh,
that it was real.
It was like,
okay,
this is you.
They're being courteous to you because they liked you on pair of a show and,
and you know,
they're not booing you.
And then so go get this money and have fun,
but don't,
don't take it serious because at any moment it's going to disappear.
You know what I'm saying?
But then that didn't happen and it became a responsibility,
like,
okay,
this is not disappearing.
You have to,
it's your responsibility to take this as far as you can.
Wow.
That's a weird,
that's a weird way of thinking about it.
So why did you think that it was going to go away?
It was it because truth is too good to be true,
man.
Yeah.
It was too good to be true for me going into the room and soundstage,
but at this,
at that time,
you know,
1520 minutes and getting five grand,
10 grams,
what?
We're talking too good to be my whatever I want to talk about.
Come on,
man.
It wasn't like some says you have to do liquid enacting.
We give you a script apart and we have to deliver this guy to the audience,
not you.
I was saying it was you,
so that was too good to be true.
I was like,
what man?
Come on man.
What's the hardest part about starting not late?
Is it that you're already set in your ways and you got to shift your whole life
around because now you're a stand up comic and know the hardest part of my
standard starting up,
sorry out that late for me was that I had most of the comedians that were my
age.
I'm 52 years old now.
Most of you look that fucking my age.
Crazy crowd.
A lot of fans their age,
you know what I'm saying?
I have fans my age,
but have also a lot of fans that are 2118 and now because of the new show,
I'm doing it with Terry crews.
Are we there yet?
Five or six years old again,
he's,
a lot of kids are popping up.
So when I started doing standup I was,
I was like,
well,
who do you want to,
who are you talking to them?
You can't talk to everybody.
You can't talk to little kids.
The same way he talks to adults and answer that came back was just be yourself
and the people who you're supposed to be talking to him on the show up.
Ones who you ain't supposed to be talking to will not come back.
You know?
And I've been doing pretty good with that and you know,
I just,
I just do me,
I don't try.
That's why I've been able to go all around the world and haven't had no problem
because when we get there,
I'm not struggling with,
oh,
I'm in Stockholm now,
so how am I going to know I'm in Stockholm.
So you're going to get the same thing in Stockholm
is you're going to get and how they will that you would get in New York.
Yeah.
Me and that's it.
That's all I can deliver it to me.
You know,
that's uh,
there's something beautiful about that that,
uh,
that's a,
that's a wisdom and an approach,
you know,
and you're 42 they don't necessarily have when you're 21,
when you're 21,
the first time I was doing standup,
you really shouldn't be talking.
You should be listening to your point of view is really irrelevant.
Yeah.
You should be talking about relationships and all that stuff.
Just 21.
It's like stabbing man.
You only had one relationship
between black folks and white folks.
You're how old again?
Yeah,
exactly.
All that kind of stuff.
You know,
I think back then I wasn't,
man,
when I started I was already in a full grown man.
He helped me out a lot too.
Yeah.
Cause he's standing.
Standup ultimately becomes about your point of view.
It becomes,
you know,
you,
you breaking down,
this is,
I've,
I've been aligned for x amount of years.
This is how I see it.
Boom.
You know,
that's what you're see your standup eventually becomes eventually.
And you were already there.
You already had so much life experience that did jump in at 42,
you know,
I mean,
oh yeah man.
And then have the nerve to,
uh,
cause it's courage and the courage to stand in and,
you know,
tell people this because I think it's funny,
I'm going to hit you with it.
You know,
now we all know as comedians that sometimes you don't get that explosion and you
don't want it.
You don't want that not to happen,
but it's a possibility.
But yet that's the risk we had to take.
Right?
Bombing Sucks bombing us.
It's what makes you sharp though.
Fear of it happening.
It's got a sharp,
it's,
you know,
it's much harder.
We out of here right now doing,
uh,
my first TV show where I'm started showing up in the midst of doing it right now
and we're going to be out there for six weeks.
And what does it,
Charlie Murphy Law.
Charlie Murphy's law.
Charlie Murphy,
me as it is to me as a judge,
like judge Mathis or whatever.
Right.
But imagine judge Mathis when he goes home
and he has it,
uh,
you know,
judge matters,
his background and he's moved from the street.
Right.
Cause he,
he adopted this kid that's a bad kid.
So He's trying to mentor this kid.
It's,
it's kind of like the courtship of Eddie's father with your son is not,
he's not soft.
Your son is really a problem every week it's going to be some drama with this
kid where I may have to really,
you know,
you know what I'm saying?
Be Dad.
You know what I'm saying?
To knuckle up and they,
cause he's not,
he's not theall right.
What I'm saying.
Right,
right.
It's a real case.
Real kid.
He's like what most people are dealing with.
Right,
right,
right.
But it's funny,
you know,
so that's,
so if you mix the two,
thinking about night court and that blended together,
that's what the jest of the show is.
It's going to be me and Nightcore.
It's going to be funny stuff in courtroom scenes or whatever,
but it's going to be mainly about me and my relationship with my adoptive son.
I
got to be looking to judge Matt this as your inspiration cause I love judge
Mathis.
Whoa.
This is a weird how it was like watching other people go to court.
Roe v Wade is that man we like watching other people go to court.
We be like other people to be able to go,
oh you're fucked now dude.
I can't believe he says motherfucker doesn't even have receipts.
No receipt.
Why?
Why do we like seeing other people fuck up?
I don't think
you can get just a nice distraction.
You constantly on their problems so you don't have to think about your own.
We've got some new thing to occupy your mind.
This is true.
I consider judge math is like school down in like it teaches me what not to do.
Just like I do with cocktails as a teaching for 48 like if I were to murder
somebody,
like I know not to do this and that
is begging skills.
He has professional badness.
I wouldn't start.
No,
no tab,
which is quick with it.
And he said some bone crushing shit,
man.
I'm telling you.
I was in a radio station with them and his jokes back,
but he really told that deep well that Dj's name,
I don't know,
got started.
He came in and started thought he had to,
you know,
slept in the room.
He came,
we keep,
first it started with Paul.
He didn't know Paul was a comedian and he freezes and he may freeze.
Actually freeze after about 10 minutes.
Hey,
hey,
are you a professional comedian?
Because the room was that glasses were knocked over and everything.
People were laughing at him.
He came in the room and started it and got blowed out.
It looked like it tall Gary Coleman.
Right.
And that's what free stuck to that whole theme,
the Gary Coleman thing.
This dude was about this time.
Oh Look,
just let Gary ripped them in the room and then we went into the,
the,
the booth,
the actual room to do the interview.
Judge Mathis,
isn't it?
So the guy just finished getting embarrassed by freeze.
He wants to redeem himself.
He says something,
you judge Mathis and judge Mathis took it to the next level.
It was,
it was like they played a relay race where they guy but ping pong.
He hasn't wig handing them off the judge man.
What a judge Mathis destroyed him.
He destroyed him.
Says,
first of all,
I just climb up out of that hole when you're talking.
Wow.
Judge Talking Shit to you.
And then at one point my man said something about uh,
downtown La.
Oh yeah.
He said some of my transvestites and inducing,
yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
Madness.
I know you want to go to an NCO limb transvestite.
He didn't judge Madsen.
Yeah.
I do want to go there.
I met so I could watch you stand up and suck Dick and dude was like real short.
Whoa.
Throwing him under the bus right now as this information that can get him.
He's a real man in prison and shit.
That dude's awesome.
We know what to tell a short dude.
Sackers watch you standing up a sec.
Dick that's dead was weird is the brain's was okay.
Don't,
don't get it twisted that that's what made me go judge Matt is the real deal.
Yeah.
He hit this dude so hard man to do.
Shut up the rest of the interview.
He was scared to talk,
man.
He was scared to ask questions.
He would kick me for scheduling ourself after
great moments and criminal history.
True Hollywood stories with judgment.
I love church.
I can watch you.
I'm supposed to Tommy,
I'm supposed to ask you about Johnny Gill who thought he could beat Oscar de la
Hoya.
Oh yeah,
man.
You know why nobody told me.
Somebody told me.
How did you know about that one man?
I think it was Thompson.
Gloria told Matt that was,
that was,
that was one of the days when that's back when the was still,
you know,
fighting too.
That's what made me really angry.
Ask her was whipping somebodies ass and I'm sitting next to a balladeer,
you know,
I respect you.
You get singing on that,
but don't point to know frankly and go,
I could whip him.
I don't want to hit that man.
He really said that vehemently man jumped up and I even,
I even up to the fact that you brought it up,
it ain't like I'm snitching.
I told him,
if I ever see you asking him the same room,
making sure that ask it knows that you feel that way.
I want to be there.
I'm making sure he knows that you uh,
balladeer crooner said that you can whip them out.
Yeah,
man,
that was a,
to me that was the highest incidence of the highest level man.
You make your money,
you roses flat in the and all that saying you gonna look at it.
Finding and talking about how could whip him.
Come on man.
He needs to know that.
He needs to know you feel that way.
I did it with Mike tasting and ran for house.
He used to talk shit.
Oh yeah,
my,
my mouth do this and that.
The Mac Bababababa so I,
one day we were all together and I said,
you don't mind.
This dude told me whip your ass man.
He really,
he tells me all the time,
why don't you tell him Mike,
would you be telling me
watch them turning the Koolaid,
his chair?
He said,
Mike,
he didn't say nothing.
She didn't say nothing to me.
That was my whole point.
I mean you probably encounter before,
I've been in the hood up in the barbershop sometime and I got to tell folks my
and be like Yo man cause Mike,
you know Mike,
Mike,
Nothing man.
What do you,
you work for ups,
right?
Don't bring up Max names,
staff it bring up another truck drive.
Cause I'll take me out to Gleason's rate now and pick out any heavyweight.
Somebody who you've never seen on TV and he'll make you call them integrators
stabbing man you don't,
you got to fire.
You don't do what this guy does respect what he does.
I him jumping around and we'll have your truck.
I'm trying to beat you on your router.
That going to happen.
It happened man.
Let's get delusional about their ability to kick ass.
He really thought he back in the day,
I don't have been.
Maybe he's more.
Thank you.
Just think that he felt,
he felt he was more powerful,
faster.
I said,
well,
you never boxed before as an the duty.
I'm talking about being a man.
I was like,
what are you
talking about being a man,
talking about being a man.
That's a dude that doesn't understand what an eight week campus or like an eight
week trial he was.
He was Buffy,
I think he was working out with bag of bars and he had a little cut on
everything.
I was like,
you know those muscles don't translate to a win,
Bro.
People get translate to best in show at the bodybuilding cancer context,
not that you and to win the fight.
And if you look at real fighters,
they don't have the chiseled body like Gi Joe.
Know what I'm saying?
Look at Anderson Silva.
Look at his body looked normal man.
Yeah.
And look what happens when those dudes come in with the,
you know the Gi Joe Kit Classic.
The problem with all that muscle muscles,
it needs fuel.
Yup.
You gotta,
you gotta feed up and see you only good for about 30 seconds,
20 seconds of full fury.
When you're all big like that guy can hang on to you.
It's like riding a bull,
you know,
but the real bad endurance,
then you burn it.
You just ride them to be aware of themselves at harms.
They fill up with blood,
then they can't move.
They get heavy.
It's crazy.
You watch like there's a guy named Marius [inaudible],
strong world's strongest man does those crazy fucking things where they throw
the beer bottles in the air and the cars and shit.
You know that strong man shit.
He's one of the bunch of times and he just started doing MMA and he gets fucked
up by fat cat.
He's throwing some punches and kicks her.
Tim Silvia beat the fuck out of that boy.
He had that dude purple.
Purple is Tim Silvia was like,
how dare you.
I was a fucking two time heavyweight champion.
We're more a maybe,
I don't know.
Either way.
It's a fucking world UFC heavyweight champion.
And you think that you can pick up a car so you can kick his ass.
It was like a slow,
methodical ass kicking by.
Uh,
an overweight guy.
Essentially.
We've got what the car's not moving cars cards,
you know,
doing techniques.
But if they can get you in those first 15 seconds,
you can have a real big fucking problem.
Cause for those,
those guys get street people are like,
you know,
yeah.
That guy who could throw a car goes to the supermarket and you get an argument.
He could probably throw you across the meat section.
Yeah,
your back or something you're going to be on.
Expect it to me across the meat section.
But you ain't an MMA fighter.
You know,
you ain't a boxer,
you ain't whatever.
Any,
any kind of professional athlete,
whatever professionally is in respected.
Don't disrespect.
Now you're thinking today though.
Now you got me thinking about fights in supermarkets.
Yeah,
Dude.
Yeah man does.
There's no weight classes in supermarkets.
No Way.
This dude was talking about
jumping on that was wanting to Renick bags
and I asked him,
yeah,
it was the same size physically.
I was like,
you really think you could beat that guy?
He said,
we're the same size as I said.
Yeah,
but I've seen him run over five guys,
his size and Mc and you run over,
get a hard time going up the steps and you to mess
this boy.
You know what I'm saying?
You got the same size but you don't.
I ain't the same thing man.
People don't understand a super athlete understanding until that's why.
That's why we have the ability to buck our eyes.
Express that,
to express that.
When you get surprised.
Oh Shit,
I didn't mean it wasn't practicing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You can't hang out with dudes and talk shit.
Talk Shit about hey,
how they'd fight Mike Tyson.
Get those guys are useless.
But now I'm telling you,
if you come around me talking about who you could whip it,
cause a lot of my friends would phrase and I've seen him in the room.
I'm not just letting them know that you feel.
That's how I,
that's how I wrote it was funny as fuck you feel
it was me,
bladder,
brack,
blah blah.
Brad Blackburn,
Maury Smith and one other,
uh Oh Ivan salivary all UFC fighters or Cape kickboxers and we're all out at a
restaurant.
And Charlie is convincing everybody that,
that the rich hand that y'all are sleeping on the ridge hand.
And he was talking about that on the Chicago Ridge hand,
the different types of rich hands.
And they were,
they were laughing.
They would try and say,
Yay like you,
you can't even,
but Charlie's stuck his fucking gun
man.
And one of the big first UFC joints,
my med check with Delta knocked out Yarbrough originating chocolate gum.
Never fuck y'all bro.
He fought some big thing to Keith Hackney.
Fuck y'all bro.
Yeah,
he did though.
He hit him.
He hit him with a Lego,
uh,
an open palm strike to the head too.
He hit him with a bunch of different things,
but he definitely,
but I would never use it.
Raise your hand.
Open Palm.
Strike that.
That even sounds like it's just going to yell.
But listen to her who just,
who just executed a beautiful over palm strike national television.
All give a round of applause right now the way Rupert Murdoch,
round of applause,
man.
What happened to see the press conference when Rupert Murdoch was getting
interviewed and this dude tried to come in with the Pi and hit him from the side
and his wife came out with the open hand palm strack and broke his nose.
Whoa wife this young.
She's not old like him.
He has it like she's like in the thirties man.
Look at him.
She didn't even hit 30 year old pizza ass shows fighting bandaid on his nose and
broke his nose.
Man.
Rupert Murdoch,
you know,
despite of all evil intention and she's hot though.
He's a bad motherfucker when that guy's got a lot of power in this world and in
any Booper kick.
Yeah,
that's incredible it.
That's what you could say.
You get it at all.
We could tell you wait,
you go take care of that day.
She comes over to us.
She knows martial laws.
By the way,
she went straight to the palmier striker.
Wait to did a nose to beat you up with Yoga.
She came with it,
man.
What an old school move though.
Hitting somebody with a pie.
Shaving cream.
We were taught what?
What's so funny about the whole thing is not long before that we were just
talking.
We were like,
what is the defense with that rallies in Charlotte asked Joe First.
Okay.
Let's say you was,
if he was doing something
live and somebody did that to you,
would you laugh it off?
Um,
it really depends.
Depends on if I felt a malice from them.
If I felt like they hated me,
if I felt like,
you know,
there were,
there were lasting Yan embarrassed,
but people try to embarrass people just because they're idiots and they want
attention.
They would,
it would all depend entirely on the moment.
But I would hope that I wouldn't do anything stupid.
So I said,
man,
I said was I would whip the person's ass.
Right?
And then he just does something stupid.
This is what he pointed out and was fine.
He said,
but you have to remember this child wants to pass on your face.
Whatever you do after that you're doing with pioneer
instant comedy.
To me it would depend on the Pi.
It'll be delicious.
It was like,
what is that limit?
Marangu fuck.
Yeah.
Thank you sir.
Are you going to get hit in the face?
It's going to happen.
Yeah.
It's like you'll be fighting with paying your face.
I was
just like,
there's a lot of prior,
just like there's a lot of dummies that we'll look at.
A guy like Mike Tyson,
I really think that they can kick his ass.
There are people that look at a guy like you like on stage and they get upset at
you for some reason and they get upset at you for getting that attention to get
up so early but they feel like they should be getting what you have.
I thank God every chair,
every time one of them have stepped up.
I had a baseball bat of jokes,
you know my,
my,
my reaction was always right on time.
Laser sharp and they was birthed out of the audience like a cigarette butt,
you know,
and he's been in a witness it and I've been in the witness,
you doing it.
I think you're one of the best I've ever seen do it.
You inspired me when I seen it.
The how
you took it.
That was like,
well I could go much harder.
Joe Is telling him this person man,
wow.
You know what I'm saying?
Can
I see you evaporate?
People says that me that told me that it's something that you definitely got to
have as part of your game.
If you're going to be standing up on the stage talking to people,
you have to have the ability to,
you
know to do that.
If it comes up and got to shoot them down and keep it moving,
you can't be haggling with them and you know cause that's going to break the
whole continuity of the show up.
The guys that can just hit him with the hammer and keep it moving
best.
But it's an unfortunate side effect of comedy.
But we started out freezing.
I were fucking comedy store veterans man.
And that was a place that nobody patrolled.
There was no manager Shush in the room does the comedy store was run by the guy
on stage and occasionally dude's got kicked out because the comic would go just
get these fucking people out of here.
God Damn.
It would get,
it would get to the point where it was just you had to kick them out and board
the show couldn't go on,
but there was always something there.
That place is always drama.
I've had glasses thrown at me on stage there.
I've seen I w we remembered when a Holtzman got knocked out by Martin Lawrence,
his body.
God Damn.
That place was chaos.
I remember.
Wow.
I remember Eddie Griffin,
we,
we were in the main room.
We had a show.
It was Martin Luther King's birthday and after the show,
this was the,
when the Dj came on,
this is the first time I heard the song a no Vaseline.
Yeah.
The Dj played it and Dr Dre and all of the dog pound and it was about doctor
Joe.
Yeah.
They were all there and,
and dre went up on stage and snatched the record off of the,
off the turntable and snapped it in half and that kicked off a riot.
Trek was in there.
Tupac was in their trach,
had that big change with the padlock on it.
He was swinging that over his head.
Oh my God.
This went on in the main room on Martin Luther King's birthday.
Wow.
I remember that.
Holy Shit.
Fucking crazy man.
His last wave plan was your prize laughs.
Yeah.
Seeing that where there's women out there,
but the counties,
I was in the parking lot,
Richard Pryor was performing that night and she was standing by the back door
and this other chick came around.
It was,
it was getting any come up about her.
She's,
they knew each other.
Harvard,
she,
she said that other chick did not tell you anything to come no more,
which shows
every time she hit it,
another piece of jury came off too.
When she got finished,
all of this women's rings and necklaces and everything and her wig was laying
on.
Wow.
And they was dragging her away,
man.
And then Richard Pride when on stages that 20 minutes on what just happened.
Classic took it straight to the state.
What year was this?
They had to be eight in the eighties man.
You're like 89 90 something like that.
Could you imagine if you fucking video tape down.
Can you imagine if you had a video tape on the mom says they're not taking it to
come no more than that,
which just shows pop pop and started firing on him.
How beautiful would that video be to watch that watch the ass kicking to prior
walking on stage to prior talking about the ass kicking to pray all it went all
three show.
Don't want to miss it.
Yeah,
I performed at 20 minutes but just having that in that I performed with Richard
Pryor for a few weeks right at the end.
Right when he was,
when he stopped performing,
when he was in a wheelchair.
My,
when they used to carry him on stage in the or room,
I had to go on after him for for weeks,
for weeks.
When he did that,
I always knew I was those the only spot Mitzi always gave me right after Richard
Pryor,
you go on there to reteach you would you would eat dick like no other time.
Yeah,
cause it wasn't,
it was sad.
It was sad,
you know?
I mean,
it was cool because once Richard would open his mouth,
it was him.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
you could tell that he's,
and then it was,
it was a weird effect because you'd be like,
oh Yo,
he's still there.
He's still in there.
But then you'd be like,
wait a minute,
he's in there.
That's his body now.
And that's what he's,
he's kind of,
it seemed like he was more in prison after you heard him do stand up because it
was a realization like this is a man who has his wits but does not have his,
his motor skills and his,
its functions is bodily functions too,
to match up with his wit.
Right,
right.
And that was,
that just was,
even though he was funny,
even though his sharp,
that just,
it was sad.
It was,
it seemed to me like there was a,
there was a disconnect too towards the end.
He,
I don't think he was completely lucid.
So when he would go on stage and talk about things like,
they didn't always make sense.
And you know,
was,
uh,
it was,
he was dying,
you know,
and he would get this huge round of applause when he got offstage where people
just say,
you know,
hey man,
when you look at him right now,
man,
there's not much time left.
And this is one of the greatest comedians,
maybe the greatest comedian to ever walk the face of the planet.
The most influential I think of all time.
And you're walking and watching them as they're carrying him away.
And then they introduce you Jeff edge against on the piano.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joe are all getting from hardball on Fox TV.
Please welcome Joe Rogan.
And you go on stage and you have to do stand up after Richard and it takes at
least four or five minutes to get them out of the room cause they're walking
with him out of the room.
They have to,
cause he can't really walk.
So they have to carry him and walk with them really slowly and everybody's
clapping and standing,
you know,
like a war veteran just got off stage,
you know?
Awesome.
That's who did just get off stage.
Yeah,
it's good one.
definitely man.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
That type of,
you know that work in spirit and in other artists too.
Like Sammy Davis Jr last film he ever did was a kid who loves Christmas and I
would happen to be in that movie and he,
that's when he was dying and
I wouldn't came to work with,
he was,
he was there every day,
you know,
he was,
he died like a week or two after we finished shooting.
He was advanced cancer,
but he won't work anyway.
Man.
Patrick Swayze did it too.
Right.
It's coming to work anyhow,
I guess.
Why not?
Fuck it.
Just go out doing what you like doing.
You think that's what Steve jobs is done.
Do you think that's why he stepped down today?
Do you know that Steve Jobs so stepped down from Apple Appleton?
I hope it doesn't change.
It's like,
well,
I don't know man.
Dude has like,
he had pancreatic cancer,
didn't they?
Or liver cancer?
I think something crazy.
He had to get a liver transplant from fighting the cancer.
Wasn't that what it was?
Yeah.
But never got fucked up from the chemo or something.
Thank you.
Had Magic Johnson,
that shit's like quickly like this.
Now he'll pay for it and it'd be done.
He just has the,
all the money in the road.
You think there would,
there would be,
you know,
that's just kind of just show you that there really isn't any help for some of
that for cancer.
You know,
you can,
you can fix aids,
but cancer,
you can't stop it no matter how much money you have.
I think some people have a genetic clashing,
they can just get it.
They just have a badge and antics thing.
They're most likely gonna die of cancer young.
That's very possible.
But there's also a thing to be said for guy works as hard as Steve Jobs,
but that shit is just not healthy.
You know,
you're,
you're hitting that red line all the time.
Yeah.
Fucking engine is constantly going,
man.
And I don't think that's healthy.
Oh No,
this can't be,
it can't be,
that's not fun.
If it's not fun,
it's not healthy.
You know?
It's that simple.
Do Europe,
billionaire son,
man.
Yeah.
And it's like,
Yo,
you have done it.
Yeah.
He really likes you really can eat some cookies.
Works in TV.
Yeah.
You know?
He's got eat like oatmeal cookies with like maple sugar.
Okay.
He's got like some serious issues with his health.
He's pretty fucked up,
you know.
And you know,
I dunno how much of that's genetic.
I Dunno.
I Dunno about that argument.
You know,
how much is genetic,
how much of it as well.
I think a lot of it has to do with diet man.
You know,
genetic diet,
all that.
Yeah.
And it's also stressed and you know,
just dress a lot of executives like Hollywood executives,
a lot of those older guys,
they start getting really sick and I think it's a lot of it is just the
pressure.
You know,
I need this one guy,
he used to work for my ex girlfriend or my ex girlfriend used to work for him or
other real nice guy,
just 50 years old,
had cancer,
you know,
out of nowhere.
And he was dead within weeks and it was just the weirdest thing ever.
It just seemed like this nice guy,
like,
hey Bob,
what's going on?
Nice to see Ya.
He's always laughing and joking around and then boom,
whatever it was,
just hit him and hit him quick.
And all of a sudden we had killed my father and my wife and put both of them.
It was like,
you know,
they get sick.
They went to the doctor and he was diagnosed.
They went into treatment and he passed away.
She wasn't like a,
you know,
it was a long battle.
Him,
you know,
and,
and we both of them,
like my dad,
he smoked,
but when he was young,
he was an athlete.
All right.
My wife didn't smoke and drink and do drugs that are worked out,
drink water every day,
didn't eat meat.
Wow.
None of that.
But still,
she didn't,
she passed away before she was 40,
and it was diagnosed,
uh,
six months after my daughter was born because he wouldn't have to keep it off
the followup checkups and then boom,
you get cancer and man.
So it's very deadly in in its origins a are a mystery because it can be what you
eat.
It could be it's in your family or it could just be you or your personality.
You're very tense person and you create an created within yourself.
It's deep,
very scary disease,
right?
Yeah.
Imbalance is a,
is a frightening thing when it comes to your health.
You know when it really could be terminal,
like you're going to have a terminal imbalance.
You could get,
your whole system is so fucked up from thinking the wrong way,
doing the wrong way,
eating the wrong way,
treating your body like shit,
treating people like shit.
And then next thing you know it,
holding on to anger,
hold on,
grab all that kind of stuff.
Holding grudges,
all of that stuff is manifest some way.
Resolving a garage,
it's one of the best feelings ever.
When you're cool with somebody,
you know when you weren't cool with them and then all of a sudden you're cool
with them.
So a nice feeling.
It's like a,
it's a good as a human being,
I took a good feeling,
you know?
That's most definitely.
Yeah.
But keeping one and just thinking about this mother fucker.
If I see this,
just hold it out in the shit like that.
Going over fake arguments and you had,
if he says this,
I don't want to say that.
It would have been
for a long time.
I would,
I,
you know,
I had to learn it.
Don't keep writing.
Just don't dwell on negative,
you know,
I had to learn it.
Yeah.
You want to be hard.
Do you want to tell them to fuck themselves for life?
Bitch,
I was,
I was reading on Twitter the other day,
somebody from a tweak,
a quote from Ben Della and he said,
um,
resentment is like,
it's like a,
it's like drinking a bottle of poison to kill your enemy.
Whoa.
That's deep.
That is deep.
It is true.
Tell,
Yeah.
It's almost like,
you know,
you got to figure out a way to make people like to make people that you hate.
People that know you.
People that only become a source of positivity to you.
Right.
Figure out a way to,
no matter how conti somebody gets guests with you never let it affect you.
Only take it as a source of vins ratio.
Right.
Twitter has made me better with with that cause it's constantly asshole.
Yeah,
that drives me nuts.
When people talk shit there and man gotten into a few people,
then I realized
going back and forth,
this person,
man,
it probably playing right now of course get lit up.
You said,
you explained to me,
he said,
Yo,
don't forget.
Look,
somebody says some real smart allocators are some some bullshit to you and then
you look and they got like seven followers,
but you retweeted what they said and what you're going to do to them.
Now.
How did you gather people's reading
or reading?
I know this person.
Anyone know what's going on?
You what I'm saying?
The best thing to do is just don't even respond.
You can't,
you can't get just block them.
Block crazy every,
yeah,
I just block them.
People want to talk a lot of shit.
They want to be angry,
man.
It's like you could choose to fuck what you choose to put on that.
Twitter is a direct reflection of you as a human being.
When you send out there,
that's you,
man.
And if you get country,
I don't need,
I don't need you and man,
I don't need you in the mix.
Put that block on you.
You take care of that and go back.
You want to talk to me that the way we should meet somewhere.
Do you know how to get to the dock?
It's funny how many people out there looking to find somebody to hate.
That's a lot of people,
man,
and a lot of people looking for you to stumble.
Point fingers.
You go fuck yourself.
I want to do that.
They want to,
you know?
I don't know.
I guess this people feel a lot of times that if you're failing,
then that makes them doing good.
I'm doing good.
I'm not Finna see.
Look,
look,
look.
It failing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the worst.
I'm happy to see him fail that piece of shit.
You're like,
man,
you don't even know that dude.
This dude never ever met that dude.
I'm glad it's not the opposite end.
Would hate to have everyone try to kiss you all the time.
Like,
like write your nice little love letters every day.
Who would it be late today?
Who Do you think would be the most annoying to be
in that respect?
Either one of them.
Man,
he could tell you I broke up with his girl once.
Faxing me.
Am I okay?
She just kept saying,
Oh really?
Oh do you?
Okay.
Yeah,
maybe I'm fine.
I'm fine.
Why don't you go get some money?
She come back.
Are you okay?
Yeah,
I'm okay.
20 minutes later.
And then they even noticed it.
So I finally said to her,
look,
I'm a grown man.
Why do you keep asking me?
I'm out.
Said,
what did you say?
What
really
helped me with my problem?
I said,
never asked me.
I'm okay again.
Do you understand?
Are you okay?
Had to storm out of the room.
Maybe she just wanted to talk,
but it wasn't a good sentence starter.
She was,
she had a problem.
She had a problem.
She had problems with.
It was weird.
Yeah.
She was really weird.
I guess that's,
that's the way to put it.
As soon as dick whipped to the point where it's irritating,
he just broke her down.
She just asking.
I don't,
we all care.
Damn.
Wow.
You didn't want that to be a finger.
You don't want somebody who,
you know that's too much.
She was just to India.
Yeah mate.
Somebody that can be too in need.
You know what I mean?
It's irritating.
Come on man.
Back up,
man.
I Dunno man.
That sounds pretty good to me.
Yeah,
no,
just need a few of them.
You had to experience
it felt sorry because she landed the role.
She's pacing in the hallway in front of my door.
Whatever are you doing here at your back?
I can't see if you're okay.
Can you see if your k
yeah,
she hot.
She was nice looking with that.
Made it ugly,
man.
Oh,
you really stuff.
She did it to the point where it was like,
look,
I'm avoiding it or course and did you ever tell her stop asking several times.
She wouldn't stop.
She couldn't step.
What was the issues?
She crazy.
She was a little,
no,
a little bit.
She's a little,
she said,
I'm obsessed with you.
I was like,
well,
it means that you have,
you should go talk to a psychiatrist if you have sex with anyone,
you,
you shouldn't be dealing with them no more.
You know you shit.
That's not probably healthy relationship obsession.
You know what?
What?
What caused the obsession?
I don't know.
Maybe like some people you can,
you just fucked the shit out of a charming dude.
You know what I'm saying?
With some piece of
shit.
He girl you broke or dude,
you broke her phone when she was like waiting outside your dog like a dog.
Are you okay?
Okay.
You guys,
she's like a bloodhound for you want something to eat?
You okay?
Okay.
How long?
How many times did you have to fuck her before you broke her?
What are you a case study from?
The first really the first session.
Now you a cancer game.
Okay.
Charlie Murphy.
Oh,
you okay.
Breaking girls.
Wills.
I must caution Charlie did a Murphy.
Then I'm going to tell you something though,
man.
I'm tattoo.
Charlie did a really didn't emerge.
Charlie did a movie that I thought was the same name as the coconut water,
isn't it?
Oh yes.
Cook out to Seel to see.
All right.
[inaudible] out too.
Yeah.
With Mike Tyson.
Mike Tyson is a scene in the movie.
Yeah.
Yeah,
too.
He's in it.
When's that coming out?
Cause that you guys from that last year or two years ago?
Two years ago.
What is it on Miami?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know where it's coming out because they,
that dude Jimmy Henchman,
he's,
you know.
Yeah.
That's what the shot Ken and I told him we was coming down in Miami.
He,
he's going to do a screening.
Oh,
okay.
One of the producers got put away,
so I don't know.
What's the wonderful other movies,
movies,
movies are finding me at my best.
My best friend was the fact that I had a chance to work with Mike.
I knew Mike Tyson before he was the champ.
You know what I'm saying?
So I seen that the whole journey from the guy who was irregular,
dude,
that was scared and you know all these people around them and tell him you could
do this.
And he did it and he became this bigger than life person all the way to,
you know,
to the end now the person that he is now,
because if you see Mike now,
Mike got his shit together.
You know what I'm saying?
He's not,
nobody could sell a,
he's outta control.
He's not out of control.
He's a married duty,
he's calm,
he's polite to people.
He doesn't get in trouble no more.
He got to laughing the dude man.
Interesting.
Yeah,
he got his shit together now.
So I feel good about that.
I got to work with them when that movie.
So that was a good feeling man.
Cause I hadn't seen him in years.
I seen him when I did see him,
he was back.
You know what I'm saying?
You've seen that documentary.
They,
I seen the document.
How fucking powerful was that with the purse strings?
We never seen that Tyson document.
Is it just called Tyson?
When you see a man cry fucking and cried when he reflects on parts of his life.
Strong man like that.
You have to realize that whatever was on it was no joke.
Yeah,
it's an incredible,
that's a man who,
one time I went to his house and it was five or six limos and nobody would get
out the limo and I said,
I come to mind is getting out the car.
They said,
hey,
you don't see that line standing over there.
Mike tastes the lane and his front yard and says
like hangover starts.
The only man who's house avid went over.
There was a lane in the front yard loose.
Wow.
He was on the steps like this heavyweight belt.
He was like,
oh no,
no.
That's not a cat.
That's a lion.
That's fucking real.
Make tastes a male or a female law.
So the main line in his front yard,
loose shit.
It was walking.
It was off the leash,
man.
He was not in a cake.
It was in the yard.
Oh my God.
They came out and started wrestling with him in mind.
Jod Damn.
How big was the lion?
It was big man.
It was a lion man he was wrestling with and grabbed him and started tussling
with him and all the [inaudible] and everybody was in the limits cause the land
could come up to a limousine and busted window open and come in there.
I'm sorry.
Easy.
He could just go like get booth from come right in there and just having lunch.
So everybody was in the car.
You couldn't back out cause it was all like
five limos.
Everybody's in the car herself.
Bad thinking.
It makes us getting ready to be eaten by this land
that isn't happy is he plays with him and he put takes him in the back.
That comes back out and I was like,
you know what,
I'm never going to be in around another man in that's going to do
that.
And you know what I'm saying cause to me he was it Mike Tyson.
Is that Elaine team?
You have everybody making working in Vegas?
No,
he's just the same lanes.
He had one in his front yard man.
But he had other cats there to Bieber would never have a lion and it'd be like
to chose all the way or something.
Boy,
I can come and guide this waiting my mcats.
Isn't that cause we've seen wild kingdom land make.
We've seen him eat Willdabeast.
The Mike Tyson story is such a classic fucking story to him and goes from being
poor to being intensely rich.
Intentionally rich.
The focus of attention of literally every person on the planet when he was at
his peak pan and the late eighties when he beat Michael Spinks crazy.
Jesus Christ.
I don't even think people today when he ate a billboard and make ms faces made
an urn,
that billboard,
I don't remember that strongest billboard on sunset.
It's an,
it's an iron.
Mike did like his face was made.
An angel just makes face awesome.
Awesome.
Uh,
building the years like the Bruce Seldon years where Bruce Seldon,
he didn't even like,
he missed him with a left talking cell.
Does knees buckle?
He got up and just said,
what am I doing getting up?
You know what?
I'm just knew better.
He knew all those guys who was a destroyer.
There's no fighter out there right now.
I think that is,
we captured their attention since,
since him not like him,
not like him.
Since him.
People don't understand.
He was Michael [inaudible] who would be charism charismatic if he was American
pack yet.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I would be like that,
but if that,
you know it's like that over he,
yeah.
If you look at the sheer numbers between the how he wasn't Tyson was,
he's probably right up there with Tyson right now.
Huh?
Close.
Not to say I definitely,
especially in Asia.
I mean he bought an la man.
Right now I'm in La and you got a wild card boxing where where he trains people
don't sit out there and wait for him.
They wait to find out what time man,
he's going to be there.
It's like a whole crowd of people there.
I did this thing with Daniel Tosh for Tasha is TV show where toss gets punched
in the head by a Manny Pacquiao.
He left honey pack.
Y'All punch him.
[inaudible] was very nice.
He's very nice.
He's just like barely tapping them and we had to do it a little harder to make
it realistic so you can put a little pop into it,
but it was nothing.
It was very nice.
But every business in that whole complex has Manny's pictures up and Manny sign
things and it's got boxing gloves on and pictures of him eating in this
restaurant that's right there and it's cool.
Yeah,
it's like there's a,
there's some,
he's huge.
He's like a super superstar and he's like,
he's a,
he deserves it.
Oh yeah.
And he's such a nice guy.
What do you think is doing women between a or teasing me?
That's a good question.
I was going to bring that up when we were talking about Tyson because I was
watching this thing on Victor Ortiz when he was talking about his childhood.
I was watching it right before we had the rover and he had a rough,
his mother when he was 12 years old or it's when he was seven years old or six
or seven.
His mother just left,
just took off,
never came back.
So
he's only raised by his dad and his dad just beat the shit out of them,
hit them with sticks,
hit them with anything.
And then when they were 12 his dad left.
So it was him and his fucking brother,
like wild dogs at 12 years old taking care of themselves.
Scary shit man.
Like they,
they had,
they had nothing.
They had nothing.
Real fun.
Yeah.
And you know,
to come from that man,
there's a certain amount of resolve that that kid's going to have that the
average person is not going to have,
but it's not going to be enough to deal with Floyd motherfucking Mayweather dude
cause flooding in,
whether it was an artist,
there's,
you know,
love him or hate him for like his personality and the way he attracts fans and
the way,
you know,
gets flamboyant,
crazy skillfully.
Forget all that skillfully.
He's a fucking master boxer.
He's a master.
He's very rarely in any trouble.
He gets hit.
He can take a shot.
Shane Mosley,
Bang,
shame on that button.
The division with it stop.
Well,
it wouldn't have been able to recover the way Mayweather did everything
appropriate to add them up.
He recovered,
he took his time before he jumped back going.
And he was,
it was beautiful man.
He's just very,
very technical.
He's,
he's,
he's technically perfect.
Like he's,
he makes these little short movements and throws guys off little quarter turns
and shots from the,
from different angles that you expect.
And it gets through what your,
you know,
he finds out what you're going to step and then he's waiting for you before you
do it.
He sorts you out,
man.
He's a real,
he's a real technical boxer.
That's what I,
I think what's going to happen with him or no teeth is going the distance it's
going to be bloody and think so.
Yeah.
Or,
and that letting him beat him and he's coming to fight,
man.
He's going to have to get beat.
Yeah.
And uh,
Mayweather's it's going to be a good fight for me was,
I think Mayweather's going to win,
but he's going to have to be Mayweather to beat him.
It ain't gonna.
He ain't gonna be able to come in and have the night off.
That dude is the real deal.
I get perhaps he'd beat my friend Andre is a good friend of my Andre Berto.
Uh,
and that was a great fight.
Great fight.
Woo showed me that this dude is no joke,
no Joe Andre Berto,
that's shatty dropped him with anybody else.
Don't get up.
That guy got back up and then put him down off of that.
So when I put you down,
I wasn't even at 100%.
I'm drunk when I do that.
Well and not so many fantasy pull that trigger be on the ground like Danny.
Right.
I didn't
get up and put the other guy down.
How often do you see that happen?
He's uh,
he's definitely a a blood and guts type fighter.
You know,
he tells himself in a dangerous going to be a good feeling that one fight where
he quit.
And ever since that one fight,
he felt terrible about that.
He was losing his fight and he got dropped and he just call the referee off and
quit.
And people really heavily criticized his heart.
But what it was was he wasn't a hundred percent focused on either his training
or fighting itself or the consequences of losing or whatever the fuck it was.
He came into a fight out of shape and shit.
That happens and some shit that young guys will do,
they'll,
they'll fuck up and they'll have a bad camp or they needed to learn something or
they needed to be pushed and broken to rebuild and come back again.
So ever since that fight,
he's been a fucking monster.
That Murdo fight was insane.
I thought Berto was like the next challenger to Mayweather.
I say like,
this guy is so tactical of a Berto is as well.
Berlin is a sniper.
September 30th freaking went up.
He's a real accurate puncher too.
That guy's a sniper.
He's,
yeah,
he's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
I thought he was going to be the next time when on warranties beat him.
I was,
I was blown away.
I kids Tov and he's got,
he got a lot better.
You've got a lot better from that one fight.
You could tell the one fight where he quit from then on his dedication is
obviously been way,
way more foot.
Waist.
Yeah.
Cause now he's,
the way he wanted it was the way he will be Berto.
What that does for your confidence.
Yeah,
that's,
that's it's going to be what much more than if he just came in,
stopped them early is that he had a grueling contest with these men came out on
top,
you know,
so that they really just a laugh.
Forget what you,
do you think that there's any way that may,
whether it was going to be rusting because he keeps taking these like year and a
half breaks,
two year breaks in between fights.
Well I think the reason why he's doing that,
it's because his hands,
you know what I'm saying?
That's his hands in a good,
good time between five to,
he'll have,
he's a holder,
you know what I'm saying?
They break really isn't right.
His broken up my sheet lab,
sometimes hands.
So he's preserving his hands.
Yeah,
he's,
but he's still trains clicking a dagger doggies around the clock.
He's training,
you know whether he's got a fight coming up in a nice his lifestyle.
So I don't think he's rusty at.
So you think he's just constantly stairs?
They bring them in.
He whips guys answers every week man.
Whether you get it framed coming up and that really?
Yeah.
The guys come on,
I'm going to the Gym,
light him up.
He works out.
He's always in shape.
He doesn't get,
he doesn't get in shape during camp.
He's already in shape when he gets there,
you know,
just showed us everything.
They showed his training camp to show him hitting the pads.
It's ridiculous man.
Nobody had some has like he does too.
And a lot of it is this type of puppet.
The puppet just combinations pipped up,
up,
up.
So he just wants the fucking combination.
Since the zone get tired,
these are just relaxed and everything's flowing.
Yeah.
Was ridiculous.
Routine is insane.
Well he's a master and he doesn't does it from a standing position.
Yeah.
He doesn't take much punishment,
man.
He's a guy.
He's been a boxer for a long time and he looks perfect.
Lucid,
nothing wrong with him.
He's got no scars,
not busted up.
And what does that Mike Tyson,
Mike Tyson with his line just wrestling around with it and stuff like that in
the video.
I didn't make that a 19 year old,
20 year old Mike Tyson right there.
This right here.
Pass the Mike Tyson and foster a tag.
My God,
he's got a fucking tiger.
He has a line to the beginning,
but he had one them.
Oh my.
How could that end?
Well,
yeah,
it doesn't end well.
If you eat them long enough,
it doesn't anywhere.
They always kill it.
Right?
Eventually.
Yeah.
Come on man.
They can make a mistake.
They might not even do it on purpose.
Joe Kill you by accident.
Yeah,
but he's not what happened to take freedom,
Roy,
he didn't get placed.
You and kid,
the Siegfried and Roy,
that guy got killed like one little took off side of his face.
Well,
he didn't he
die,
right?
He,
um,
he got just got really badly wounded.
And what happened was the,
the uh,
they think that the tiger got confused because a woman had feathers in her hair,
like some crazy peacock feathers and they think that it's higher amount of
freaked out and thought that was an animal.
So grabbed him to rescue him,
to pull him away from that.
You got Joan Rivers.
So the tiger lifted that feather thing and thought that was one of those fucking
beats from Avatar.
Sunbelt was just going to pop out of the audience.
Who in the hell is dead wrong?
A manatee to can grabbed him by his neck and just drag it
them off?
Jesus Christ.
Why?
What does that feel like when you hear your bones and your neck snapping and
cracklin inside the mall of this enormous beast?
At that point,
your brain is saying this was a tiger,
right?
We're in here with you.
Right?
That's what it's just reality is
what the fuck was I thinking?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's hard for us to really wrap our heads around the fact that shit like that
really exists.
The Tigers and bears.
And did you hear about that lady in Russia that got eaten by a bear while she
was calling her mother on the phone?
What?
The fucking bears don't kill you man.
They just start eating you.
That's one of the things about maritime house and started eating it.
No,
they were hiking.
Her and her stepfather were hiking and then killed her stepfather first and she
got to her cell phone and she's calling the cell phone.
She's calling her mother while this fucking bear is eating her leg.
The bears eating her leg and she's screaming and screaming in the phone calls.
She called her like three times over a period of an hour.
Well,
this bear was eating her alive.
Where was this?
Internet comes in Russia.
Can you hear the audio online?
Bryan Park.
It was a woman as a woman and she was caught.
She kept calling her mother while she was being eaten and I thought,
no,
there's no audio clip.
That'd be the worst audio cleo.
But they found,
yeah,
they found the body.
They found that dude dead.
And,
uh,
he,
the bear was eating the guy when they got there and the girl had been what?
She died from her injuries.
What was it?
A Russian black bear and grizzly bear rushing Christie.
I believe it was because I think that's what the,
the article I said that I wrote the side.
But you know any kind of bare from Kelly yet.
How sad is people will be going up in these areas with that's positive one.
No,
we haven't gotten what she,
you know what I mean?
Well you didn't get have a gun.
I didn't have a really big one.
You got a better,
a really big one.
If you see a grizzly bear with a regular gun might not be good enough in his
mouth.
Might be good enough.
So even if
you bagged me,
I'm blowing your teeth out.
Yeah,
maybe rang me up that full stiff in your mouth.
What about a Koala blow?
The roof of your mouth.
The is a vicious,
if you're a female Koala beat the crap out of me.
You fuck up a Koala Bass is what is this a fat cat?
Well,
we got shop clause.
Here's the move a Koala bears on the move.
He's headed towards you.
What's your first step?
Chicken and drop kicking him.
Drop kicking like a photocopy pun.
Tell me a short prompt.
Him.
You'd have to kick him right into running into a look eucalyptus.
You got to hope that he doesn't.
Somehow another time you lifting the foot up and just run right up your pants
and your deck as you go to swing you just a little off timing.
Any stories up your leg and Joe White on your Dick.
Cause they only eat eucalyptus.
That's it.
That's all the,
yeah,
don't take,
I believe Koala bears raped the fuck out of female qualifiers.
Oh,
so they have to be strong and they have to have a good bite.
If they can pull that off,
I might've made that up.
And for the boss,
I know.
Devil,
they're rapists.
They're not real.
That's a real answer.
Did exist.
It's a real animal.
Yeah it does.
I'm thinking the Tasmanian Tiger,
Tasmanian Tiger did exist.
It was in uh,
Australia,
but they went extinct.
But the Tasmanian devil was a real animal.
It is.
It looks like a little rat family type thing,
but yeah,
they raped,
they raped the female body,
but rape man,
half of their body is,
is I think like a little bit over half of their body is jaw muscle.
God Damn there.
Their whole,
they're just basically a mouth walking around and they fight from birth until
death.
Yeah.
They fight any other Tasmanian invite when they're born constantly.
How big are they?
They're,
they're big now.
That's something that would like get ahold of your foot when you try to kick in.
Yeah.
You wouldn't want to kick this ugly man.
Oh my God.
Look at the images this motherfucker and they yell totally shit.
That's like a crazy cartoon pedo bare face.
Like vampire bears.
Look at this thing or this thing.
Thank rat bears,
right man.
Look at that thing.
Wow.
They will fuck you up to very no jokes,
dad.
You shouldn't be angry.
That's when I game.
Yeah,
those little,
there's like a few of these little type of crazy animals that scared the shit
out of me.
You know of different species like wolverines and like honey badgers and shit
like that.
They scare the fuck out of me man,
because they're only,
they might only be like 15,
20 pounds,
but they'll kill you.
Most gravity man,
they're like to sting rays of the forest.
They'll kill you.
A honey badger would kill a person.
It just would need some time.
Yeah.
I've never heard of a honeybadger talking about talking about them to hit one
sentence,
but then
you watch these uh,
these shows by dogs,
different breeds of dogs.
There's a,
it's a Badgett honeybadger you're talking about.
There's a terrier who specializes in him and killing the honeybadger.
They come with like 30 of these dogs.
He may kill like the first five.
Jesus,
Feisty.
When they come,
they go into his dad and they go in there and bringing out God
then and bring him out Dell terriers and though he may kill like the first four
or five to come in there.
The other ones then that affected by the death of the reds and he's coming home.
He's like a real live Bruce Lee honeybadger.
All the songs are coming in and he's just fucking them up left and right.
Taking them out some and they drag him out and show the them.
They labeled and drag them out.
It says the most fearless animal on earth,
they said about the honey badger don't give a fuck.
And the police videos
the online that say honey badgers doesn't give a fuck.
And it's like all these videos of honey badgers eaten cobras are chasing dumb.
Anything that's in front of them,
they kill poisons stinks all day.
They just too fast.
They just sneak up behind the snake,
bite him in the head,
and sometimes they get bit,
they get hidden by the venom and you know what happens?
They fall asleep and they wake up an hour later and then they eat the snake
though he's going to kill me.
Blacked out from venom and these little crazy murderers body processed the venom
and he got up like he was drunk and you start eating that snake again,
snake bit him with its poison and the poisoned didn't do ship and make them take
a fucking nap.
Wow,
honey badgers must be from Brooklyn.
I can just imagine if they could talk,
they'd have a Brooklyn accent.
Honey badges don't even speak,
Bro.
There's no need for language and their thumb.
They're thinking,
they're thinking that there's no variables and they're thinking you don't need
language.
Fuck kill sleep.
That's what the honeybadger for.
Wake up.
Do it again.
Just realize how weak we are.
Man was so flashy and too like just nothing to see planet of the apes.
I see.
Did you like it and laughed?
He laughed.
It was funny.
I went to see planet of the apes cause I was like,
I know it's going to be some material.
I loved it.
I love the guests.
Can see when he came home,
when he left the girl out,
what it was like prison stuff
wasn't me.
It was a monkey doing the Levi's,
uh,
James Commercial at the end of the movie though when it was last very last scene
and he was standing on the branch overlooking San Francisco.
That pose he had,
it was like,
that's not a chimp pros man.
I said,
man,
suppose to say he's selling some jeans or shirts,
doctors or something.
You know what he was doing?
He was standing there,
he had his hand up,
he was looking gay dads
looking at the Golden Gate Bridge and all that.
I was like,
Nigga,
this shit man.
It's true.
It was weird when it sexy,
sexy money.
Yes,
your monkey moves man.
That was the whole thing.
He was,
but he wasn't.
But he was a supercharged super monkey man.
He was a monkey smartest people.
He was an alien and like,
yeah,
he was.
I just,
I'm down for any movie with Champs.
Fuck people up.
I love watching chimps.
I love the way they move,
man.
It's fucking shocking.
When you,
you ever watched any of those things where they would teach chimps,
had a sign their own names and they can teach them how to spell things and that
when there would a spell it correctly,
they would get candy.
So they learn how to spell certain things and point certain things out.
And,
uh,
this one chimp,
they would let him into the cage and the first thing they have to do is
establish dominance.
So as soon as you open this thing up,
he's a big fucking fully grown,
like eight year old male.
So he comes in and just starts fucking throwing himself through the air.
He's like a buck 60,
a buck 70,
just hurls himself through the kitchens,
the cage,
the cage back and forth.
Hurls himself through the Kachin bars.
And you just look at the strength that he displays and you watch it happen.
You,
you watch him throw his body around and we're just realize what he could do to
you.
And then he sits
down and then a play with you.
And then it was like,
you know,
you put this things out,
it takes his candy,
eats it,
but he just wants to let you know what the fuck he could do.
No,
like he's some flowers or candy or whatever.
I could come over there and just smack you around.
I thought planet of the apes was good.
I didn't think it was that funny.
I thought I liked it.
I liked that gas can come on.
It was pretty funny.
Not the gorilla,
the gorilla.
He knew he was smart.
He looked a bit loud.
Oh,
right there.
Isn't it funny or final destination that knew I movie has the best three d yet
the seeing that stupid movie three d read.
I do not want to see him move or as a bunch of people just dying.
What's creative thought it with that movie?
Yeah.
Did you ever see the old ones though?
Like like that not highway scene where the semis are gone.
Like I can like just crazy car accident.
It's pretty cool.
Fucking awesome movie,
but it's a fun movie I guess.
MMM.
No,
no,
no.
I don't have that kind of free time to show a thousand ways to die.
It's now why?
No,
no,
no.
That shows kind of funny.
I was just funny.
It was hilarious.
The problem with his final destination movies to me,
he's like,
oh,
he is,
he's getting acupuncture.
How's it going to be?
Oh,
now he's dead.
I respect the special effects,
but other than that,
it's like,
what am just watching a bunch of people died.
Curse.
This new one has a bridge that's collapsing.
It's broken in the middle and it's during rush hour and he's just like,
the car is skidding and he was just in three.
Wow.
So that part's cool.
I'm sure.
But you haven't seen it.
That's what I've been told.
I was saying it's like awesome.
Three d if you liked that shit.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I'm not into movies just for three days.
I saw Conan and it wasn't three d didn't know was that the no,
it sucks and awesome.
And it's
talks at the same time because here's the deal.
The dude is the perfect Conan,
like physically the way he looks.
He looks just like Conan and me could easily be Conan like right out of the
robbery.
Howard books.
So you got that and then you got,
did you hear my kids screaming in the background?
I need a studio.
This is ridiculous.
We've got that echo.
Throw some man shit down.
Anyway,
the dude was just kidding folks.
Don't get crazy out there.
Um,
the,
uh,
the books,
where it was,
it was,
but it had no story.
It was like the,
it was like,
it was awesome in the beginning when he was a kid,
he was a bad ass kid killing everybody and it was awesome.
And then it got lame and then it got awesome again.
It was a couple of fights.
It was pretty awesome.
And then it got lame again.
It was like awesome.
And Lane.
But they needed somebody while they were making that movie to be in the room
with them going,
what,
what
you're going to do?
What?
No,
no.
They need a company that does that.
I want really the,
I want to be that company.
That's a dumb,
why would you ever do that?
You know,
this is so fake.
Konijn oh,
neat.
A three day weekend and a lot of weed and some buddies that like those kind of
movies and you can fucking figure that out and you could figure out a way to,
that was the other problem.
This dude sounded way to California.
He was like,
there was times like in deep battle,
he was a great Conan when he was fighting things and killing and yelling and
screaming.
He's a great that,
but then he was sitting down and talking.
It was like,
all right dude,
you need to work on your Coney on voice cause this shit.
You just sound like some dude.
I would meet at target.
You know?
It doesn't sound like someone who came from that era at all.
Okay,
thanks for crashing me back into reality and is honest.
Wasn't any point blank.
Yeah,
exactly.
Sounds like it's going to be hard to beat that man.
He did performance he put down was captured.
Well he showed a certain intensity,
you know,
I mean Arnold had,
first of all,
nobody is built like Arnold and the,
they're all going to look weak compared to how he looked when he was flying
around the sword.
You know,
you just don't,
you don't get a dude is built like that.
So I wouldn't see a remake with him now with you now he spent like a good hour
prep for it and the hour prep.
Yeah.
Army.
We went back to the gym.
You probably could pull it off.
Pull off that last rocky.
I mean,
uh,
I'm Sylvester Stallone.
Messes alone.
Pull that leg.
Never really let himself go.
Arnold is clearly let himself go this pictures and he had a heart problem too,
right?
Did he have a heart?
Turkey?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He probably can't juice up anymore.
The next movie's going to make is Mrs Doubtfire
lessors to loans.
You may swaths,
namely how many by at the way?
I can see my kids.
He's a fascinating guy and wow.
Wow.
Just bangs is,
it's just shooting Lowe's
and it was made while he's the mayor or governor rather head for 10 years.
Right.
He's just too raw.
But Decade of this is be quiet about this is,
is it called
banging her all day
long hill.
The governor loves you.
So weird,
man.
We imagine that poor kid has to grow up knowing that,
you know,
the governor was just banging his mom and he had a real dad that he grew up
with,
but it wasn't really his dad.
They looked just like Arnold.
That's gotta be a mind fuck and a half man.
But she getting the bodybuilding figure management,
you've got the same genes,
man.
Go hard.
Who Your father is,
get get down and goes to jail because he has a different mother.
He goes,
he's not entitled to all that cash.
It's totally different situation.
Right?
He gets sick.
He gets taken care of.
Yeah.
Well she has to.
Yeah,
he has to pay child support,
but I bet the kids probably not in the will and all that good stuff.
Oh yes he is.
You can get in the wheelchair.
It was one of his offspring,
man.
This point,
that kid can look at it as half empty or half full.
You're halfway in.
Their kid can't win halfway in there.
You can make it work.
So that's what I'm thing,
man.
I wonder how many kids Kennedy had on the side and nobody knew about them,
but 70 cent.
Now think about back in those days,
man,
they didn't have as many abortions.
They were just a woman would go live with her mom.
I'm going to live in Rochester,
Rochester,
Rochester.
That's when you know this fucking podcast has fallen off.
We can't even come up with a good comedy name for whether it's checks 11
we were,
we peaked with the,
the honeybadger and that was at the honeybadger.
Charlie's checking his Twitter.
We're all falling asleep.
No I'm not.
I'm just making sure that that Trump,
listen,
I would go into that.
What's the name of the club?
We're going to hit 1616 what's that?
It's a club in downtown.
I'm like that's going to hit that 1616 doing comedy tonight street.
Yeah.
That's where you're doing it at this place.
You ever go down there?
That's when I started talking about it earlier,
but we got off the subject.
I was talking about how you going when,
I mean we are here for six weeks,
so that's why every week we'd go do the laugh factory knew going,
getting ready to go downtown.
I don't just sit back and go,
okay,
I'm doing a TV show on making money.
Uh,
Al do comedy when it's over because I know that the county's is going to suffer.
What I'm saying.
You take eight weeks off and don't do no stand up.
No Way.
When you go back eight weeks later,
your next show is going to be as good as your last one.
You know what I mean?
True.
There's no way it's going to be,
you know,
you got to get it back,
get all your feet back up under you again and so to
take you to get your feedback on.
Yeah.
One
takes one,
one,
one good one.
If I stay off off the stage for like two weeks,
I never hardly stayed or more than two weeks so I took a month off once.
That was the longest ever took off.
It's a weird feeling,
right?
It's weird.
You feel hard for atlas man.
In fact,
I went last night and we went,
I went on at the laugh factory.
That was the first time for me in three weeks and I told him on the way down and
I was like,
Yo man,
I can't believe how much anxiety as fear right now.
I feel like,
like I'm really scared right now.
Like,
like I'm feeling like I might get down there and go,
I'm not going up.
You know what I'm saying?
But I of course I went up,
but that feeling was,
was their man for just snap going up,
you know,
for three weeks,
man,
that's the number one enemy of comedy,
you know,
worry that worries.
They're worried,
you know,
especially if you go on,
when we went,
when we went to the last fat laugh factory,
the week before that scene,
three dynamic guys come in and blow it up,
you know,
and that I was taking that week off.
So when I came back the next week,
I'm like,
you're going up.
But you seem to dudes that come through here it is that no slouches in here,
man.
You know what I'm saying?
For the most part,
you don't want to come up with the big,
it's Charlie Marino
and then you know you ain't,
you ain't,
you worry about that a lot.
Yeah,
definitely.
So that's especially coming into the game late with a very,
very famous brother too.
So I don't want nobody to come say,
oh,
when I seen him and he was,
he was nothing,
you know,
I want you to say I seen him and he,
dudes,
it's working at his craft.
He's going hard at it.
I could see the work he puts in it and he's funny.
So the only way I can try to,
you know,
have any plane and put the work in,
I can't force you to like me,
but I could work hard,
you know?
But you're enjoying it too,
right.
I'm loving it,
man.
I'm loving it.
And being a part of the community of comedians and everything,
the whole experience,
you know,
it's uh,
it's great,
you know,
that is a big part of it.
And the community people that should meet,
you know,
in my opinion,
there are no dumb comedians,
you know,
to be a community,
you got to have a certain level of intelligence is very few communities that I
would go,
that's a dumb guy.
You know,
pretty smart people that should meet,
you know,
and they,
we'll look at things as interesting,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
they uh,
if their good especially,
you know,
it's about,
you could have a real issue,
a real smart,
this was the guy's name from South Africa.
The other name.
Oh
Wow.
Trevor's something smart.
Kids from smart man.
Very Smart car.
SMART,
smart.
I love comedians like that.
Not Saying,
not taking this chair,
but he said this,
he said,
I flew 20 hours head from South Africa.
I really had a hard time and I did my research and I didn't want to offend
anyone.
I found this,
this one organization called the Klu Klux Klan,
very racist organization.
And it just baffled me that Ku Klux Klan actually means circle of brothers
to be someone that hates black people.
Why would you call yourself the second
that was fun?
The whole name down,
his name is Trevor.
Some Kevis sound and he broke down was Shit Klux Klan man.
He broke that part down.
I believe he made it to a very funny joke.
It was very funny.
He's talking about African Americans.
He said,
he said,
even though they're not real Africans,
right.
No one ever pointed that out.
That's funny one here.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause he's from Africa.
So when he came and said that it was hilarious and I was watching all these
films and trying to get all my black lingual a Yo B,
what up then the minute I got off the plane,
everyone thought that I was a Mexican because he's hilarious.
Light a South African dude.
That's funny.
Dude is brave man.
He's a good dude.
Trevor's smart comedians.
You know guys that actually took the time to think about what they're getting
married.
Well I think people in different countries are being exposed to stand up.
They were never exposed to before.
The Internet to your standup was pretty much what your culture was like.
The English sweep or had their own sense of humor.
The Americans,
different cities.
We had our own different sense of humor.
But now because of the Internet,
everyone sends a humor,
gets distributed worldwide.
So people get influenced by all sorts of different artists from all over the
place.
You want me to tell you the one thing I remember about you,
it was when you used to do the Anna Nicole Smith stuff.
But the thing I remember is I never knew who she was before.
I heard your before.
I heard your comedy on her,
your comedy,
and we went and sought this checkout.
Oh,
that's fun.
You didn't know the whole story.
I didn't know anything.
This was way back in the day.
But you know,
you had to haul.
Oh Dude,
I wasn't,
it was like,
who is he talking about and,
and why does stripper married a billionaire?
Yeah,
there was no internet back then.
There was no internet.
We had to come get it from the horse's mouth.
You know,
that story was so awesome.
I mean,
I,
there was a hundred different comedians and had beds all night.
He couldn't pass it.
Ours was,
yeah,
yours was classic.
Nice man.
It was fun.
Stir.
Well,
when something like that comes along for comedian for more than,
you know,
some people go,
oh,
the world's falling apart.
Comedian looks at something like that goes,
Oh yeah,
look what I got here.
Exactly.
I just found some money.
I went to go see playing in the games.
I was like,
I know I'm getting a bit at it.
Yeah.
You can't go though thinking that way.
You got to go and just enjoy getting in and out of it.
I was like,
there you go,
man.
He could have just smoked up and had a good fucking time like I did for,
there'll be another movie to come along.
And they always,
they always want aliens.
They always read one when I sit down and watch it at home.
Okay.
Yeah.
I couldn't do it myself.
Thank you very much.
I couldn't make a movie myself,
but I'm fucking very critical,
you know,
it was a lot of movies.
Just support,
bore the shit out of me.
I can't do it myself rather than one that's not boring
to people.
You know,
I wrote it for paramount.
It's about the movie is about,
uh,
the sec a slasher movie,
but it's a comedy.
It's a dark comedy about,
uh,
these two guys that used to be pimps ready.
It establishes them as pimps in the beginning of the movie and they'd get out of
the pimping game because there's some gangster dudes that come in,
come to town and take over the whole industry.
Every industry pimping gambling.
Whenever you're doing these guys are gangsters.
Didn't take over the whole shit.
So how the dealers,
pimps quit,
quit,
quit pimping,
but before they do it,
they set these two guys up and these two guys get locked up.
They get a life sentence.
They said two guys up and they rob them for a $1 million.
This is,
it takes place like a 79 when what million dollars seem like it would last
forever and they give that speech.
This is the big one.
Breath,
nothing cool Mickey.
This is enough money for my kids and my kids' kids.
I keep $1 million and it's two guys getting ready,
so they set the guys up,
they get the money.
The guys go to jail 25 30 years later,
these guys get out because life is only 25 years now the other two guys are
totally not street.
They haven't been street with 30 years.
Then randomly guys,
these dudes been in prison.
They was hard when they went to prison and came out even worse and they figure
out that these guys did what they did.
They're looking for them.
They want their money back.
And these guys have to pretend that they're something that pretended that Jews
standing and where you really don't want to bother us because we could kill you.
I know you're tough and all that,
but you've been in jail.
You don't know what's going on out here.
Now we run this,
but it's all an act.
And the guys that are with them are actors from an acting school.
And they fooled these guys very briefly in the movie.
But when they realize that it was a trick,
they go back to the acting school,
beat up all the actors,
find out who told you what the whole plan was,
how you,
what the plan was to use the triggers.
Now that after those guys,
now while all this is happening,
there's a stalk and the movies serial killer,
it kills only pimps.
It's called the pimp store.
So from the beginning of the movie all the way to the hand while the story is
unfolding with these two guys that stole his money and they basically trying to
find a way to give them money back without getting killed.
It's like,
like in that movie,
uh,
which way is up with a bill Cosby and Sidney Poitier,
the type of thing we did a Flim Flam we want to find our way out of it.
Give you your money back.
Get out of it while they're trying to do this.
There's the pimp stalker killing preamps.
The cops think that the two guys that are after them,
all the pimps,
stalkers.
What?
He's not.
They're not
Brian.
I'm loving it man.
I'm going to quiz you on the plot.
Yeah,
cause I'm on to Plat.
All right.
Okay,
so,
so there's this serial killer dude.
He hates Pam once in a murder or a mall.
And then there's this group of pimps that are ruined the city with these other
groups of guys came in and someone goes to jail for something.
Huh?
Crypt.
Because 25 years life.
That's life.
That's life nowadays.
When do you get when you get five years is his life.
If I give you life in prison,
that's 25 years.
Really?
So after 25 years you can get out.
That's crazy.
Now sometimes it's life without parole.
That's what they have to say.
Life without parole.
They say like you can get out.
Wow.
So these guys get out.
You know what I'm saying?
And they're after these two dudes who are now like soccer dads with big guts on,
dude works at the church,
you know,
you know he did that and that street people anymore and they're forced to go
back into the world that they snuck away from to pretend you know,
for a little while.
But it doesn't work.
They get caught.
You guys want their money back.
It's all,
you know.
I don't want to get too deep in.
They probably already did.
The Shit is funny.
Did you write your book also or do you write up my book too?
That's awesome.
It's not your book's about you not doing it again.
I'm a better writer than I am a pitcher.
Pitcher.
I just am.
You know,
you read scribbled,
you would understand it a whole lot better than me sitting here.
You know what the problem is it to you and the problem with telling us 30
seconds you start and then you got to keep going because then you've got express
things happening.
You've got a lot of shit going on,
a lot of shit.
It's hard to pay attention.
All that shit.
Special effects.
You gotta show me some shit.
Shit looking at you.
You gotta show me some Shit Shit going on in the movie.
The movie's funny.
The only thing that may change by the movie is the title because the word pimps
again,
I'm like I to have to come up with something better than that.
The movie is not,
I don't want people to think of movies.
He comes to see a movie about Pam.
So that's not what it's about.
The movies about these two guys that went straight and then element is trying to
draw them back.
Charlie Murphy,
what we need is Goddamn TV.
She'll phone you around and talk.
Well and I've got something like that I'm doing with Terry crews.
Man called up my bed.
We're going to,
once I deal with the bio channel and it's going to be me and Terry crews,
the pilot is me doing,
you know,
telling you a story about something that I did to a person years ago that was
fucked up,
you know,
and then I do a reenactment of what I did to the person and then I go back and
find the person and I give them their money back.
My idea for charming back in 74 and he thought that by written by Bob,
and you thought that I was with you when I set you up to be robbed.
And it was all of that,
you know,
and I give the guy his money back and I'm apologizing.
So what are we going to do on a bio channels?
Everyone has something,
maybe not as extreme as me,
but southern that you did is somebody in your pants that you wouldn't mind
apologizing for saying,
Hey,
you know what I did Bob about and I'm sorry,
and we're going to use all celebrities,
every celebrity guest,
somebody
that he did something fucked up to.
Who Do you do something fucked up to Joe?
Trying to think.
Why are you saying that,
that you would like to,
that you never apologized and she wouldn't mind apologizing.
Maybe Peter Chin.
Oh,
I did keep him from hosting
[inaudible] nuts.
He was doing that shit as a joke.
Chris Mcguire was auditioning for Mitzi.
Mitzi thinks it's funny to let Peter Chan host the open mic night.
Fucking brutal man is wrong.
I mean something's wrong with Peter Chan.
And he was fighting and he would,
uh,
it was almost like a parody of like the worst common camera.
Like,
you know,
explain,
explain Peter Chan
Chin is a,
he was a nice guy offstage,
but there's something wrong.
Yeah.
It,
there was something wrong because his comedy was so bad that you would,
you would,
you would sit in the audience and literally start hating him.
Barely,
you know,
kind of comes aggressively guy.
He was aggressively bad.
Like you would be like,
why is he,
how dare this idiot?
And he had a,
he had,
um,
he like,
he,
he over accented and,
uh,
his,
his accent,
that wasn't even a real accent.
Oh is is,
is,
uh,
well he had a bad English II.
A funny thing happened on the way to seven revenue.
Uh,
I was like,
Yo,
what are you doing?
Was any part of Don Buress is a,
she used to dad.
What is that?
What it used to call Brian?
Ding Dong.
Ding Dong shut down.
We would have these,
all these,
the worst comedians possible and the country like this fish,
all the misfit crazy people and put together a Ding Dong show.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
he's got amazing tolerance,
and he would always be hanging around with these cats is these characters and
these,
these dudes.
So there's anybody that I would apologize,
maybe that guy,
cause I did bump in one night at the comedy store,
but I did it for my friend.
That had to be another,
I mean it doesn't have to be at another entertainment.
It could be anyone.
Okay.
Somebody did something to in fifth grade.
I think it's a great idea.
That's a great idea to be on the bio,
but it's gonna be me and Terry going with different people at the part where I
come in and the reenactment,
we're going to always make the reenactment comedy,
you know,
I think it's a great idea,
but I think the world's being starved from a Charlie Murphy TV show.
That's what I'm saying.
So he used to follow you.
We got that,
we got that.
And we also got the other show I'm doing and I think that's going to be rich
falling asleep.
But so we had,
we had,
there was the whole digital thing.
We get ready to build up,
you know it's going to be a camera.
The whole digital thing.
Yeah.
We gave me only a man such as Charlie Murphy can get away with saying that,
you know the whole digital thing.
Oh that's one thing that's going on right now.
Yo.
Nothing up building my whole digital department of know money and you started a
podcast.
I am.
That's all [inaudible] mom,
Joe,
this all in the makings.
But I only could do one thing at a time and what I was focusing on this year,
it was right in that movie.
I just finished writing and you know,
getting ready to do the TV show.
I mean we do a 20 episodes over the next six weeks.
What I'm getting,
I'm focusing on those two things and once that's done,
boom,
then it's onto the next,
the next area.
I'm not there.
I don't sit back on my hunches at all.
Definitely not.
You got DVDs,
books and movies,
everything and like you got to go website everything with the wife man.
Yeah,
exactly.
I keep working hard.
I'll have one eventually.
You know,
it says it's going to be hard to marry after your wife dies.
What does it feel?
It's not going to be hard to marry.
It's hard to be single.
Being single.
It sucks.
Especially if you've got kids because like I have to sneak the APP stacks,
man.
Come on man.
You go through that when you were in high school.
But if you have your person that you're married to happens to pass away or
whatever,
you can't bring chicks around and bone them kids.
You can't do that man.
Especially not being filed or you lie,
you can't sneak them up to the room,
any of that.
Because when they come in and if you have a daughter,
she's going to go,
Hey,
who is that?
That's when my daughter got,
then she goes right over to the person.
Start monopolizing them.
Who are you?
What are you doing here?
And she makes sure,
so you're having a sleep over and no she's not.
So you had to sneak.
Yeah man.
Being singles and you know after you were married for years,
it's wack.
Well I was married for years,
so I want to,
you know,
the lifestyle,
my wife is gone,
but the lifestyle,
yeah,
I missed that man.
Definitely being single sex,
make single checks.
Don't cook for you.
You don't want them to cook.
You don't even trust them.
Especially if they suggest to you is actually spaghetti.
And I don't know.
No,
no,
no.
You know,
you gotta be married.
It's trusted him to,
you know,
enjoy those things.
It's also gotta be hard when you're on the road,
you know,
you're on the road constantly.
It's hard to spend time with someone.
They get to know them once you take them with you and you can't take somebody
with you.
They own life going on.
And if you say come with me and you get basically saying quit your job,
but I'm not telling no one to quit the job.
He had quit your job and come with me.
Oh No,
I'm not doing that.
So he said,
he say it's hard man.
Especially when you barely know them.
You know,
cause that's really what it is.
Until you live with someone,
you don't really don't know him that well.
You do,
but you don't.
You don't,
you don't see you live with and that's a key part and that's when they can get
to know
about a year of living with someone.
I mean living with someone,
you got to,
you got to say at least three years,
cause something's going to have three years is a good time.
She's rails be asked at some point.
Right,
right,
right.
You get to know the person,
man,
so you know,
that's,
that's like my,
that's the paradox in my life right now.
You know,
people were looking go easy.
Everyone likes him,
he's doing great in his business and then it's showbiz and blah blah blah.
Yes,
that's good.
But that's not real life.
That's a job.
A real life is my family.
My real life is when you come home with Nate and lights go off,
you get on stage and that's the part where there's a big hole because my wife is
going and it's not as simple as one would think,
oh,
it's hard.
It's harder than you would think as far as friends,
somebody to to fill in that area.
Of course there's plenty of people would say,
oh,
I would do it outcome,
but it's not the person you want.
You have to be very careful.
You have run the children.
Yeah man.
I want to slap a few of these chicks.
Okay.
How can I move in with you to take care of your children?
Really,
you will,
you,
you a horror.
Okay.
What are you guys with that
or
get confused by the accent.
I thought it was an inside joke that I was missing out on
tuition for your brother.
And while you're actually touring as a comedian,
that's gotta be really hard.
Yeah.
Nick is,
I got my kids with me.
At any rate,
I got my son sends in your living room right now.
Yeah,
I got my kids out here with me right there.
And you know,
schools giving a start.
So they're going to be with me till September 6th taking them back home,
hanging out with him that week.
School starts then you know that that was back when we get gotta get new
jerseys.
That's a judge.
You still in the live in New Jersey and Pennsylvania too.
But this was in Philly last weekend,
man.
Yeah.
I live in having a house in Strausberg.
No,
but I'm just saying once that goes back into effect,
I'm still going to be coming.
I gotta come back out here,
work on the show.
I got to go to Europe,
I got to go to Cuba.
It's the jar.
We're so,
I can't complain,
but I'm glad I had the job.
But that's the part of it that the fact that their mother is that here,
that makes it really rough.
Yeah.
I automatically,
I was leaving you with your mind was I wouldn't even,
I been to get us to go.
Right.
I'm not leaving with you.
What's your mom's leaving you with nannies.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause my whole family lives out here on the west coast or whatever and because
I'm at the kind of person that,
you know,
leans on people like that,
I appreciate your help,
but I'm going to ask him for it and if you don't or if I'm,
I'm not going to complain about it.
I do it myself.
Yeah.
And that's how I raised my kids.
You know what I'm saying?
I got paid,
my name's,
I don't ask somebody to help me out.
I'll do what I got to do with the same time.
There's a feeling that goes along with that and then don't feel good,
you know,
as,
how do you do like video conferencing with your kids?
Yeah.
You try to do as much as possible.
I got Skype and all that,
but that's good.
Yeah.
Young man.
I got a five year old daughter,
you know,
and just don't want this.
The thing you do is to support them.
Be The thing that,
that,
uh,
disabled.
Right?
You don't like when they grow up and my father was never home,
he was always working and blah,
blah,
blah.
And that's the reason why,
you know,
my life went this way.
That's my fear.
You know,
Ryan,
I work with that one constantly.
You know,
that's the,
the fear of every father.
How much time can you spend in doing what you want to do for a living?
If you don't do it,
he's getting molded or whatever.
You don't teach him,
he's going to learn somewhere else,
you know?
And it may be,
you know,
warped sense of,
uh,
like me for instance,
when I was growing up,
my dad was always at work,
always.
I was seeing one day a week Saturday and usually I wasn't big to,
you know,
to be nasty,
but that's what he was getting your ass whipped for what you did during,
during the week.
You know what I'm saying?
Yes.
When you dad showed up to whip your ass and sanity
as a result,
when I grew up and became a man,
when it came time for me to deal with women,
I learned how to deal with women by listening to guys that were in the street
bombs,
guys,
nick t bone is slick and big willies,
whatever.
And because of that,
the first couple of relationships I had with women,
I was abusive.
Dude,
man,
I would think to think what you're talking back to me,
the answers I'm supposed to hit you because that's what slick told me.
That's not what you're supposed to do.
If your dad is there to teach you that,
you know better.
But if you don't grow up with that around you grew up with something else
because you're going to be seeking in hours,
you go,
you go out and do the wrong thing.
You know?
So that's what I think about what my kids that I want to,
you want to be at and make sure you did deliver all the lessons they need.
But then when you go to half my team is gone.
Is that not to do about that?
It makes it real scared.
Especially when you start looking at,
well all the people who are talking about they want to be the replacement you go
must be out of your mind.
You're thinking,
what bring you bring you around.
I mean our relationship is fine over here,
but do you think it would bring you,
I think we found the show.
This is the show,
this show.
The show was doing so calm on what's really fucking going on in your life now.
Well that's why,
that's why the show I'm doing,
it's not their job to sign.
And that is exactly see me dealing with my kids,
man,
Ma.
And I'm single.
I'm going to have the same,
you know,
challenges as I have in my real life and I could definitely bring it,
uh,
experience.
Do you ever do you ever,
I have done it,
but my kids don't.
Kids don't like to be at work with you,
you know,
for no longer than five minutes.
When they get there,
they check it out,
but okay.
And then where's the toy?
Is that,
where's my world?
Where's the kitty things at?
So I had my kids with me on the road when their mom was alive,
but since she's passed away,
I haven't had them with me because I'm a horrible,
uh,
fun buddy for a kid.
We'd go to Seattle.
Oh,
let's go,
let's go check out too.
I'll be in the room going,
well,
if I go there,
um,
I have to sign autographs and take pictures.
I'm not going to be able to do it the way you guys,
so,
and it's gone.
It's gone.
You don't go to just like go to Disneyland.
I have to go on certain days,
man.
You what I'm saying?
I don't go when it's,
when it's peak,
you know everybody's dead because then I become goofy or,
or,
or Mickey Mouse.
You know what I'm saying?
To the people who came here on vacation.
You know,
like the other day we were standing on a vine on 1717 branches hotel called the
Red Berry,
right?
It's right on the walk of fame and all that.
My kids in the hotel looking out the balcony,
we want to go for a walk and I said,
okay,
you can go for a walk with the nanny.
It's no way.
I want to walk on the walk of fame in broad daylight with my kids.
And I know that that's a tourist attractions.
People on buses,
you know,
driving around here,
the tour buses,
driving around on the star searches or what have you,
and if you,
from Kansas or wherever you may be from him and you go to Hollywood and you see
someone you seen on television,
what are you going to do?
You're going to go crazy and you should.
So that's why I was like,
you better stay in your room because if you go down there with your kids,
it's not going to be,
have you ever thought about it like disguises,
like blonde way?
Absolutely not.
I refuse.
I
really blew that actually happened on Patrick.
They brand new Saint Patrick's Day parade a week before that it was a blackout
in my town.
Had lost power my house for like a week,
staying in New York and in London hotel.
So Saint Patrick's Day was during that week.
I wasn't,
I'm an Irish email on,
my name is Murphy.
I don't see and I'll be aware of when Saint Patrick's Day is coming up,
you know,
so it does.
Last name is Rogan and I don't know why it's coming up.
I walked outside with,
you know my two kids and he was walking around Manhattan supposedly going to
walk over to central park and I see all of the hoop alone fit ma'am.
And I'm like,
Oh,
it's St Patrick's Day.
Do you kids want to go to the Saint Patrick's Day parade?
He was like,
Yeah Daddy.
Because they had never been.
I walked him,
just me and my two kids,
man.
I walked him up to the crowd,
put my daughter on my shoulder and we were watching the parade and hurt
somebody.
Go,
Yo,
that's Charlie Murphy.
Then it started from this side,
the left and the right.
And then you see the people looking at you and they're coming forward.
And my daughter started screaming,
man,
because it was a lot of people and they had a pressed on the wall,
the building
screaming and my daughter's screaming,
you know,
and from fear,
man,
I'm holding my son's arm and it had to just turn it into like an animal man.
Get the f out of here.
That's just pushed through the crowd.
And I looked my kids,
man,
and that's,
I'm doing it.
I'm going,
you're an idiot.
What made you think that you could stand on fifth avenue in,
in broad daylight,
on Saint Patrick's day and of crowd with your children.
And that was the safe thing to do.
But I forgotten for that one split second what I do for a living,
it came,
you know what I'm saying?
You can't make the of me,
there's
blonde wig and that's what I would,
yeah,
wrestling.
No one would bother you.
Never wearing a disguise cause you're not fooling anyone.
They look over it and go that so and so with a disguise on.
I could be a furry and you would never know that Joe Rogan over there.
Yeah,
that'd be a Fox.
That's what it would be.
One of those dudes wandering around that don't mind.
People coming up to me,
you know,
if I'm,
I'm not with my kids,
it's part of it.
But when you were children,
it's different.
You were thinking about this safety or whatever,
especially in a crowded situation.
And then when you have somebody that's really not acting like an adult jumping
around and screaming loud,
that's hard fans who a kid,
man.
You know?
So yeah,
I'm really,
I'm real sensitive about that.
You know,
which I shouldn't be.
I'm a parent,
I guess any,
any parent would be,
you don't see that somebody skin shit.
Jolen no,
of course.
I'm sensitive about that too.
You gotta you gotta be careful.
But I go everywhere.
I just go places,
you know,
I beat people most,
most of the time people leave me alone.
And when people say,
how are they usually pretty nice.
And when I'm with my kids,
very rarely do they ask for pictures and then I just say,
man,
come on man,
you got my kid
zero.
And Luckily you could pretty much take care of business if you have to like,
let me see,
Louis C K had an episode last week about the same thing happening where he was
out with his kids and these two guys came up and started like,
yeah,
we're going to get you,
you know like get his kids and stuff like that.
It was fucking scary.
Oh Wow.
And it,
but you know,
Louie is not a big guy and these guys were like big and the show and stuff.
But that's too scary.
I had that thing where,
you know,
the way most people became and know me,
the way my nap name was pronounced to them as it stream is the way they say it
back.
Okay.
You're not screaming men just because they excited.
That's the way it Charlie Murphy,
were you supposed to say it?
How you supposed to say?
So when you get 10 people doing it from different directions and you're holding
your kid who doesn't even,
you know,
understanding any of the dynamics of that,
it's going to scare the shit out your kid.
You talked to Dave Chappelle.
Yeah,
I talked to him last week,
man.
David,
how's he doing?
He's doing it right.
He's still doing some stand up,
you know,
uh,
and uh,
that's divided as far as what I know that he's involved in.
I heard a rumor that he was doing something on the Internet,
but I don't think that's true.
Yeah,
I heard that wrong.
And Chubb,
I just wish the guy would do more standup and I wish it would put out some DVDs
or something,
you know,
cause a brilliant comedian man.
Just when's the last time you heard that one of his bed though?
You know,
it's just,
it's unfortunate,
you know,
I mean,
I love a guy like Louis C K and puts out a new,
a DVD every year or so,
but I just wished,
you know,
David puts something out.
Well,
you know,
I would think that eventually he's going to have to,
because yes.
To be doing something.
I mean,
he may have had a lot of money when he first walked away.
What?
You're spending any money?
Eventually you had to do something right.
You know,
you had to put something out and do something.
Can you just go,
I'm going to have enough went into the red last the rest of my life.
When you had kids,
she got four kids.
All right.
Exactly.
Dave.
Dave lives in Ohio,
right?
Yeah.
Even when even in Ohio,
$1 million ain't gonna last you very long,
man.
A couple of million dollars.
But you know,
you got to work with what's Ohio all about?
Why is live out there?
Oh,
it was very sheltered life.
You got money moved to Ohio.
Kids are going to be,
you have to worry about nothing,
man.
What do you mean safe man?
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's not a fast moving place.
Oh,
I says not a lot of,
you know,
crime and all that other stuff.
I grew up in Ohio.
Oh.
He lives on a farm.
Really?
He lives near hippies like silver springs or high or whatever.
It's like a lot of the hippies over there.
Really good skiing.
Yeah.
Hippies in a farm.
All right folks.
That's how we're going to end this hippies in the farm.
So the good life,
you'll never see me do it,
Charlie.
It's been a lot of fun being your friend,
man.
It's been a lot of fun meeting you.
Had a great time doing that and we're going to do it.
Cool.
We're going to do it again,
man.
I'm gonna do something.
I would love to have something with you.
I'm just glad we got this done because we've been trying to do this for about
two years.
Yeah,
we've been talking about feeling like Joe Joe at this point probably thinks that
I'm foot as age.
Nah,
man.
Joe,
I'm want to come through your podcast.
I want to come through and come through Joe and,
but we were never here.
I know your business.
Fucking,
I know you've got kids cause I'm busy as fuck and I got kids.
I know what it never here man.
No worries.
Dude.
It was fun about it.
NTU in Hawaii too.
That was kind of crazy.
Just reel me in Hawaii.
It was when I first started writing it movie that just fits on that.
On that vacation is when I started writing.
That's what ruined the vacation.
I don't know where we were staying at the same hotel together,
brainstorming and all that small roles.
Relaxing
man.
And that was with a girl who I,
I don't know if you've seen her.
I was in love with that girl or that girl,
the one I took the away fell in love with the girl then with the kids and I was
like,
this is going to be the one that introduced to my children.
And she was perfect.
And then we had a conversation and she told me,
uh,
you know,
I just realized from observing you and your children that you're a pussy of a
father.
Well,
how's like,
well what did she tell you?
Give your kids are,
that would be one.
And it's two reasons why.
One is because they lost the mom and the other ones because you feel guilty
because you go on the road.
But when I meet your kids and when they introduced in the tough love and I was
like,
really?
All right,
well I talked to you later.
I've never talked to him again since then.
And that was the girl.
I hadn't Hawaii anytime.
Wow.
What do you mean going to introduce my kids to tough love.
Whoa.
Yeah,
that's instinctual.
The mothers don't like other children.
You know,
the,
the new wife doesn't like the,
uh,
the,
the children of the lost mother.
Natural.
It's natural.
It's very,
you're going to have to find
a powerful woman.
You know,
a woman who a is really pure and honest and loving and you know someone who
really is going to love and respect those kids.
Let's fucking do this.
Let them know if you're doing anything to my kids.
If you are a defendant,
was anything I'm going to match.
We're gonna match your contribution to you.
How many evil stepmother
in the,
in,
in movies and stories.
It's always evil.
Stepmothers.
Yeah.
I don't play that Shit,
man.
Yeah,
because I've seen it here yet.
Yeah.
You come around my kids,
if my kids tell me anything,
I hear you said it did.
And then when I was not around,
I'm taking your word for it.
That's what my team right now,
you know,
and that,
that's,
you know,
that's what I,
I'll look at it.
That's why you ain't grown person that comes in and you can help whatever,
but you're not,
you're not making them.
One comes with,
you're a good man.
Charlie Murphy.
That happened.
Thanks for coming over,
dude.
Thanks for having me,
man.
Um,
I'm going to have to move this Kevin Smith one.
Uh,
Kevin,
I got to call you up.
You're not supposed to find out about it this way,
but,
uh,
it was supposed to be August 30th.
Kevin Smith is doing it,
but we're going to have to move that and uh,
and that's it freaks.
Thanks for tuning in.
Um,
if you,
uh,
can thank our sponsor is the flashlight.
What does it
flashlight number one,
sex toy from men.
Joe,
if he goes on here,
number one site,
you have a coupon code.
You put in the name Brogan,
15% off,
and you can fuck and think that you're saving money.
It's even better.
Okay.
All right.
That's it folks.
That's what's up.
Uh,
I gotta update this Ustream Page,
man of the Twitter page.
Different dates.
Yeah.
I was going to say what they are,
but I don't remember him because w this is a fucking mass.
Oh,
okay.
September 30th,
I'm at the Warner Theater in Washington DC.
That's a new one.
And then V,
the Verizon Center in Houston,
Texas.
October 7th.
And,
uh,
that's it.
So I'll see you guys next week.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Thank you too.
Charlie Murphy.
Thank you.
Freeze love rich.
Wake up,
which is wake up rich.
Goodnight everybody.
Thank you very much.